Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere
kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Pridlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 110.
Ausgabe von Raumzeit.
Und heute haben wir wieder mal ein interessantes Themenfeld im Auge und zwar
geht es um die Medizin oder genauer es geht um den menschlichen Körper,
der spielt ja auch in der Raumfahrt eine große Rolle.
Und dafür begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner, Hans-Christian Gunga. Schönen guten Tag.
Schönen guten Tag.
Herr Gunga, ja, Sie sind schon lange dabei, sag ich mal, und sind schon einiges
gewesen. Da sprechen wir auch gleich mal drüber.
Vor allem aber auch Lehrer für Weltraummedizin und extreme Umwelten.
Mit anderen Worten, die haben sich ganz intensiv mit dem menschlichen Körper
beschäftigt und tun das auch heute noch? Oder?
Immer noch.
Immer noch. Lässt man dann auch nicht so richtig sein.
Es gibt genug andere extreme Umwelten, die einen immer noch überraschen.
Ja, das stimmt. Podcast zum Beispiel ist auch sehr extrem.
Genau und über die Grenzen des menschlichen Körpers möchten wir heute mal so ein bisschen sprechen.
Aber fangen wir doch mal einfach mit Ihnen an. Wie fing es denn an?
War Medizin schon immer Ihr Ding?
Nee eigentlich nicht. Es war eher das Interesse daran, wie sich das Leben auf
diesem Planeten entwickelt hat. Also Leben im Prinzip.
Ja, da wird man Biologe eigentlich in der Regel.
Genau, das bin ich ja auch zusätzlich. Zur Medizin, ich habe ein sehr großes
Schwein gehabt, dass ich Eltern gehabt habe.
Die haben allen dreien, also ich habe einen älteren Bruder und eine jüngere Schwester.
Und wir haben von zu Hause gesagt, ihr habt jeder 20 Semester,
die ihr studieren könnt.
Was ihr dann macht, ist eure Sache, bringt nur ein Examen her.
Das ist ein gewisser Luxus. 20, da träumen einige von heutzutage.
Diese Vorgabe war verbunden mit einer Verpflichtung, dass man das,
was man da macht, ernst nimmt, aber das ist natürlich schon sehr großzügig.
Und so haben wir das auch alle drei benutzt. Jeder hat von uns zwei Studiengänge gemacht.
Ich habe halt Geologie und dann später hinzu Humanmedizin studiert.
Mein Bruder hat Theologie studiert. Ich komme aus einem evangelischen Pfarrhaus in Westfalen.
Und meine Schwester hat Psychologie und Theologie studiert.
Ich bin ja mit der Geologie so ein bisschen dazwischen.
Geologie, ok das ist ja interessant. Wenn man so auf der Suche nach dem Verständnis
des menschlichen Seins ist, spielt das ja auch eine große Rolle.
Ja, das ist ein interessanter Einstieg den sie machen, aber es ist eigentlich sehr viel basaler. dann,
Wie gesagt ich komme aus Westfalen, so einem klitzekleinen Kaff,
das also auf den Landkarten kaum verzeichnet ist, man musste irgendwas haben,
was einen daraus herausbringt.
Das war immer mein Gefühl und da ist die Geologie oder ganz speziell natürlich die,
wenn es ums vergangene Leben geht, die Paläontologie, Die hat mich eigentlich
richtig interessiert, also man muss Geologie und Paläontologie im Prinzip,
wenn man Paläontologie studiert, muss man Geologie auch studieren.
Aber mich interessiert insbesondere immer diese Entwicklungsgeschichte des Lebens
und tatsächlich diese Möglichkeit auch aus dem engen Pfarrhaushaus ein bisschen
auszuflüchten und sich dann irgendwo in Steinbrüchen herumzutreiben und so ein
bisschen sein eigenes Leben führen zu können.
Denn in der Regel hatte nicht so jemand Lust da mit rumzukrauchen am Wochenende
da in irgendwelchen kalkieren Steinbrüchen.
Also das war so ein bisschen auch ein Fluchtpunkt im Nachhinein wäre das einem eher klar.
Ja in der Geologie steckt die Zeit Raumzeit 75 hier hat er auch diesen schönen
Titel geologische Zeit wo ich mich mit Karl Urwein mal so über diese,
Weltenaufzeichnung, Geologie,
unterhalten habe, was man halt sozusagen überhaupt der Erde alles so ablesen
kann, wie sich Leben entwickelt hat, wie sich die Welt, die Erde entwickelt
hat, was man daraus natürlich auch an kosmischen Zusammenhängen ablesen kann.
Ja, Paläontologie, das heißt mussten auch Dinosaurier untersucht werden, gehört ja dazu.
Ja, aber da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, als ich dann das Paläontologiestudium
machte, was mir dann ein bisschen gegen den Strich ging, Das sieht er wirklich, wenn man damit ...
Mit den Lehrern oder Fachkollegen, die da einen unterrichtet haben,
gesehen hat, die sind dann so spezialisiert auf irgendeinen Knochen,
den sie bis ins Letzte genau hin beschreiben, also mich hat immer eher die Funktion
dieses Knochen interessiert, als der Knochen an sich, sondern wie funktionieren
eigentlich diese Tiere.
Aber das konnte man also damals, das ist jetzt auch schon 40 Jahre her oder
so, das war ein bisschen schwierig.
Da haben sich schon einige Szenen ausgebissen an dem Thema.
Aber da war ich irgendwie, da stockte dann so ein bisschen das Interesse und
da hab ich gedacht okay, da hat sich auch noch die Möglichkeit gegeben,
dass ich dann einen Medizinplatz bekam.
Hatten sie sich nicht irgendwie gerade explizit mit der Größe der Dinosaurier beschäftigt?
Ja das hab ich dann gemacht, aber aus dem Blickwinkel nachher des Mediziners oder des Physiologen.
Das war noch vor Jurassic Park, danach wurde es ja total sexy.
Das kam dann dazu, dass dieses Thema auf einmal so wahnsinnig virulent wurde
und wenn man voranfragen,
wie denn eigentlich so ein Saurier gelebt hat oder was der gegessen hat und
so weiter, das waren dann alles Fragen, die waren dann auf einmal ziemlich wichtig für viele Leute.
Warum auch immer.
In dem Augenblick kam das Thema auf und dann haben wir eine Forschergruppe gebildet
mit Hilfe der deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft.
Und dann nachher, aus meiner Sicht nur 2, 3 die sich beschäftigen,
nachher 30 Leute, die sich da um den Saurier auch zum Beispiel im Naturkundemuseum.
Aber es ist ja auch faszinierend, also ich glaube...
Was macht die Faszination von den Sauriern aus für die Menschen?
Ich meine das ist auf der einen Seite eben diese Größe, weil irgendwas was größer
ist es wirkt ja dann erstmal per se mächtiger und man stelle sich vor hier würden
überall so 30 Meter lange Viecher durch die Gegend stampfen,
wäre schon ein bisschen beunruhigend.
Andererseits beherrschten sie sozusagen ihr Ökosystem, aber dann ist halt auch
dieser Fatalismus mit von heute auf morgen war es dann vorbei,
dann kam irgendwie der Komet und das war es.
Also ich denke da steckt eine ganze Menge drin, auch so an eigenen Ängsten,
die Menschen vielleicht so vor sich her schieben.
Und auch einfach eine Faszination, dass man sich eine Welt vorstellen muss oder
auch die rekonstruieren muss, in der die gelebt haben, das ist ja eigentlich
wie so ein Theaterstück, das wir entwickeln.
Da muss man sehen, okay der muss auch was zu fressen haben, was hat der eigentlich
gefressen, da sieht man die konnten eigentlich gar nicht viel fressen,
denn die hatten nur ein geringes Menü, da muss man überlegen,
wie viel müssen sie davon fressen.
Also dann hat man eine ganze Reihe von Fragestellen, die sich wie so kriminalistisch
herangehen muss, um herauszukriegen, kann man das mit heutigen Methoden rekonstruieren.
Und dann kommt dazu, dass da ganz ulkige Sachen passieren.
Ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel an eine Situation, wo ich dem Hahn-Meitner-Institut,
das ist hier eigentlich so ein Institut gewesen, das sich mit Radionukloiden
beschäftigt, also Zerfallsprodukten vom Uran.
Die riefen mich auf einmal an, ich hatte gesagt, sie sollten mal analysieren,
woraus diese Bestandteile dieser Knochen da eigentlich bestehen,
was das jetzt ist. Das ist ja nicht mehr die eigentliche Knochensubstanz,
man sieht zwar, wie der Knochen aufgewacht ist, aber das sind andere Mineralien.
Riefen im Nachmittag, wo haben sie den Knochen denn her?
Deutlich hat der zu viel Uran, 236 oder so etwas.
Offensichtlich war dieser Saurier, der war da irgendwie in einem Delta,
ist der verstorben und in der Gänge muss irgendwo eine größere Uran Ablagerung
gewesen sein und dieses ganze Uran hat sich dann in diese Knochen da eingebildet
und wenn man da mit dem Geigerzähler dran ist,
dann tickert das Ding. Das Ding lag im Erkundungsmuseum.
Solche Überraschungen kann man dann auch erleben. Und daraus ergeben sich dann
wieder so Bilder von Landschaften,
wie muss das gewesen sein, damit so etwas überhaupt zustande kommt,
wo muss was abgetragen werden, also diese ganzen Veränderungen,
die die Welt erfährt, das ist eigentlich großartig.
Das ist mir so gegangen, die Tatsache, dass so diese schweren Dinger fliegen konnten.
Ja, das ist mir bis heute nicht klar.
Den einigen von denen, dieser Pteranodon, der hat eine Spannbreite von 14 Meter und 16 Meter,
wenn sie den Körper angucken, wie man da eine Lunge reinkriegt,
wie man da ein Herz reinkriegt, wie man da eine vernünftige Durchblutung,
ich meine natürlich segeln können die aber, die müssen erstmal in die Luft kommen.
Und ehrlich gesagt, das ist mir zum Beispiel noch nicht klar und ich hatte schon
mal mit einem Kollegen, ontologisch, wo man da mal eine Arbeit schreibt,
wo man sagt, okay, wie haben die das gelöst?
Ja, denn ich meine das kostet erstmal viel Kraft den Auftritt zu bekommen,
nachher wenn sie segeln, ja, aber irgendwann müssen sie auch runter,
müssen irgendwann was trinken oder so, aber da kommen ein ganzer Sack Fragen
hinterher, wenn man sich mit dem Leben beschäftigt, wieso das so möglich ist.
Auch weil die Luft dicker ist also es war die die Luft war ja anders und dass
das ist Natürlich hat sich im Laufe der Jahrmilliarden unsere Erde verändert,
aber was zum Beispiel Sauerstoffanteil angeht.
Ungefähr, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, nach dem Karbon. Im Karbonzeitalter
hatten wir eine höhere Sauerstoffkonzentration aufgrund der starken Vegetation.
Aber danach, die letzten zwei, dreihundert Millionen Jahre,
ist die Zusammensetzung der Atmosphäre nach den Erkenntnissen aus verschiedenen
Mikroorganismen, wo man weiß, wenn dieses Isotop da eingelagert wird,
dann ist da so und so viel Sauerstoff da, ist das gleich geblieben.
Wir haben 21% Sauerstoff seit mehreren Millimetern.
Und in der Phase haben die angefangen zu fliegen?
Ja, ja. Aber ich dachte das ist schon vorher gemacht worden.
Ne, ne, ne. Also die Luftzusammensetzung, der Luftdruck insofern,
der war im Prinzip über diese Spanngeleitung.
Das macht es uns natürlich in der Rekonstruktion auch leichter,
wenn wir nämlich andere Sauerstoffkonzentrationen zum Beispiel annehmen,
da haben sie ganz andere Schwierigkeiten als Physiologe jetzt etwas zu rekonstruieren.
Aber das in der Periode wo die Saurier gelebt haben, waren also die heutigen Verhältnisse.
Okay da bin ich falsch informiert.
Okay, so aber dabei ist es dann nicht geblieben mit der Geologie und der Paläontologie,
sondern die Medizin kam noch dazu einfach um sich jetzt noch tiefer rein zu nerven.
Wie gesagt, das eine ist immer sehr beschreibend gewesen in der Paleontologie,
dass man Knochen gefunden hat, jetzt konnte man sozusagen, tatsächlich versteht man die Abläufe.
Physiologie beschreibt die Lebensprozesse. Was muss da sein,
damit ein Organismus lebt?
Was zeichnet den eigentlich aus? Und dann sind natürlich solche Objekte wie
so ein riesiger Saurier oder Wale oder Tiere,
die in irgendwelchen extremen Umwelten leben, besonders interessante Beispiele,
weil man an denen sozusagen austesten kann, wo liegt der Knackpunkt eigentlich des Organismus.
Ist jetzt der Sauerstoffbedarf, den ich habe, wenn ich in die Höhe gehe, nimmt der ab?
Dann habe ich weniger Sauerstoff in der Atmosphäre, dann habe ich da ein Problem
mit dem Sauerstofftransport.
Oder gehe ich in die Tiefe, dann habe ich eine Veränderung mit dem Wasserdruck,
der da herrscht. Und diese Fragen
zeigen dann auf, wo ist eigentlich das schwächste Glied in der Kette?
Warum jetzt zum Beispiel ein Organismus hier und dort nicht sich aufhalten kann.
Und das hat mich dann besonders interessiert, weil man da herauskriegen kann,
wie funktioniert das Leben eigentlich.
Also diese Grenzobjekte nennen wir sie mal, wenn man die studiert,
dann kommt man der Sache schon auf die eine oder andere Weise näher. und.
Das war dann so in den 80ern, ne, ihr Studium ungefähr.
Ich hatte dann noch, eine Zeit lang habe ich beides zusammen gemacht,
habe ich studiert, also Medizin und habe gleichzeitig die Rückseite des Mondes
untersucht, das sind auch nicht viele Leute mit denen man sich da unterhalten kann.
Da ist aber eine interessante Arbeit raus geworden,
die jetzt tatsächlich vor den letzten zwei, drei Jahren haben sich diese Ergebnisse,
die damals theoretisch abgeleitet haben, nach jetzigem Stand bestätigt haben,
dass der Mond also langsam schrumpft und dabei kommt es dann zu Verwerfungen
und diese Verwerfungen an der Oberfläche, die habe ich damals untersucht.
Aber wie gesagt da konnte man sich weltweit mit fünf Leuten vielleicht unterhalten,
da wird es auch ein bisschen einsam dann, als Wissenschaftler.
Ok, die meisten zieht es ja dann immer in die Tinten. Wenn sie dann ein Date
haben oder so etwas und sie sagen ok ich habe aber schon Rückseite zum Mond, das ist schränkend.
Da findet man die wirklich interessanten Menschen dann, muss man ein bisschen durchhalten.
Aber dann kam der Mensch in extremen Umwelten in den Fokus und da war der Ausgangspunkt
tatsächlich die Raumfahrt.
Auf der einen Seite hatte ich diese Affinität zur Raumfahrt durch diese Geschichte
mit der Planetologie, also die zwei Jahre die ich da gearbeitet hatte in dem
planetologischen Institut und mich mit der Rückseite des Mondes beschäftigte.
Und auf der anderen Seite waren dann die Astronauten, die gerade damals in Deutschland,
das war am Beginn der Shuttle Missionen, und da war Berlin natürlich ganz vorne
weg, weil hier gab es den Professor Kirsch, der bei den ersten Missionen dabei war.
Also einer der sozusagen der Gründungsväter der Weltraummedizin hier in Berlin.
Bei dem bin ich auch gelandet, hab bei dem bearbeitet, hab bei dem die Promotion
geschrieben und tatsächlich nachher wurde ich auf den dann zu gründen.
Professur berufen. Aber extreme, also ich richtig verstehe,
weil ihr Interesse eigentlich davon geleitet, sozusagen den Menschen im Extrem
zu beobachten, um daraus Rückschlüsse zu ziehen, über was macht denn jetzt sozusagen
eigentlich den Körper aus.
Ich meine auf der anderen Seite hat man ja, Diesen Gegeneffekt,
wenn man irgendwie gar nichts mehr macht und nur noch rumliegt und so weiter,
dann bildet sich halt alles zurück in dem Moment,
wo man ja extrem dann ausgesetzt ist, also besondere Leistungen vollbringen
muss, an den Grenzen eben arbeitet, dann macht der Körper dann auch wiederum Schritte dahin.
Die Evolution findet dann im Kleinen auch sehr schnell statt.
Ja, aber da ist, wenn wir hier bei Ihrem Thema Raum und Zeit nehmen,
ist es natürlich so, dass tatsächlich, wenn ich jetzt eine Veränderung habe,
die relativ zum Beispiel, nehmen wir den Extremfall die Schwerelosigkeit.
Ich meine, wenn Sie in der Raumfahrt jemanden untersuchen, dann haben Sie die
Gelegenheit sozusagen den Körper in eine völlig neue Umwelt zu bringen.
Und dann schauen sie sich an, wie erstmal der Gesamtorganismus,
aber auch dann Organe, Organsysteme, Zellen, wie die darauf reagieren.
Und das machen die sehr in unterschiedlich schneller Weise, also manche neuronalen
Veränderungen sind sehr rasch, andere mit dem Knochen oder Muskeln,
die brauchen Tage, Wochen.
Und diese unterschiedlichen Zeitgänge sind natürlich hochinteressant zu sehen,
wo greift die Gravitation sozusagen in den Bauplan eines Organismus ein,
da sind wir wieder beim Saurer.
Ich meine so ein Ding zu konstruieren, die Schwerkraft war damals genauso da,
das ist eine komplizierte Geschichte.
Also da müssen sie sehr viel an Struktur aufbauen, damit sie so ein 60,
70, 80 Tonnen Geschöpf auf der Erde herumlaufen lassen können.
Im Wasser sieht das wieder ein bisschen anders aus, da hat man Auftrieb,
aber an Land ist das schon eine ziemlich komplexe Angelegenheit.
Und der Astronaut hat mit dem anderen Teil zu tun. Es ist ja so,
wenn die in die Schwerlose gekommen ist, so als wenn wir hier in diesem Raum
jetzt gerade das Licht ausschalten.
Das geht ja so zack und schon geht es los,
schon tickt die Uhr und natürlich das wirklich faszinierende ist,
dass das Leben so konstruiert ist, dass es sich, obwohl es diesen Zustand nun
wirklich nicht gehabt hat, außer sagen wir mal die neun Monate,
die man vielleicht im Fruchtwasser da rumschwimmt, die Zeit,
die ist hier auf der Erde, 10, 20, 30, 40,
50 Jahre und dann machen sie das einfach weg und dann sehen sie,
wie der Körper sich da anpasst.
Das finde ich, ist eine ultimative Gelegenheit für einen Physiologen oder Mediziner,
sowas mal zu untersuchen zu können. Das konnte keiner vorher,
bevor wir die Raumfahrt...
Sie können nicht hier Schwerelosigkeit auf der Erde erzeugen,
im Parabel fliegen, 20 Sekunden.
Ja, 21. Kommt auf die Parabel, die sind auch 30. Ich hatte die Gelegenheit schon mal.
Das ist wirklich ein sehr...
Wer es beim bekommt ist gut.
Ja da hab ich Glück gehabt, jemand anderes nicht so viel gegabt.
Andere werden da schön grün im Gesicht.
Das ist wirklich sehr interessant, wenn es so von einem Moment wirklich auf
den anderen alles anders ist.
Man auch die Welt eben anders dann zum Teil auch wahrnimmt,
was auch Gravitations, wir denken mal so in der Vertikalen,
wie dann auf einmal so komplexe, natürlich unser Gehirn und unsere Strukturen
sind darauf angelegt, dass wir so einen klaren Schwerkraftvektor haben,
aber wenn der auf einmal wegfällt, ist es wirklich hochinteressant zu sehen.
Wie lange dauert das? Die Astronauten haben gerade mit der Raumkrankheit zu
70% damit zu tun die ersten 5-6 Tage.
Also auch so einen kurzen Aufenthalt im All, das kann auch tatsächlich stark
in die Hose gehen, wenn es einem übel ist.
Muss man auf jeden Fall gut drauf vorbereitet sein. Was ich faszinierend fand,
das bestätigt was sie sagen, war also in dem Moment wo die Schwerkraft für mich
gefühlt wegfiel, aber ich fiel ja sozusagen genauso schnell wie sie normalerweise
mich nach unten zieht, von daher hab ich sie nicht mehr bemerkt.
Und dann war ich mit nichts mehr in Verbindung und das erste was mir aufgefallen ist so,
ah, ich verliere die vollständige Kontrolle über meine Bewegung,
ich konnte mich an nichts abstoßen, ich hätte mich theoretisch durch die Luft
schwimmen können oder so, das war's dann aber auch, und dieser Verlust,
dieser Kontrollverlust an der Stelle war dann wirklich so der erste Aha.
Und man kann sich das zwar irgendwie vorher versuchen klarzumachen oder so,
aber es ist dann doch nochmal ein bisschen anders, wenn es dann auch wirklich soweit ist.
Das interessante daran ist, genau das was sie beschreiben, ist die Tatsache,
dass der Körper dauernd nach Informationen sucht, sich zu orientieren.
Er sucht danach, er hat hunderte von Millionen Rezeptoren,
zum Beispiel was Druck angeht, wo ich hier jetzt sitze, wo mein Körper irgendwo,
das sind dauernd Informationen die fließen ein um meine Kontrolle über den Raum zu machen.
Zu haben wie ich mich da bewege aber in dem Augenblick wo ich eben die schwere
losgekommen und dann wirklich da im Schwebe dann passiert genau das jetzt sucht
mein System händeringend,
was ist das Wort danach irgendwo in Kontakt damit ich damit ihren Informationen
darüber kriege wie bin ich jetzt eigentlich hier in dem Raum sortiert.
Und wenn man die nicht kriegt wird's schwierig. Ähnlichen
Effekt hat man wenn man in so einen vollständig schallbefreiten Raum geht's
gibt so was im Bereich der Audio Technik wo man dann so extrem alles isoliert
das also überhaupt kein Hall mehr da ist und in so einen Raum rein zu gehen
ist sowas von beklemmend.
Schmerz würde jetzt zu weit gehen, aber es ist halt sowas.
Das ist schon eine Art von Folter, also wenn man das länger macht,
das ist ja leider Gottes, der Mensch kriegt dann immer auf die skurrilsten Ideen,
aber das ist ein Teil einer Folter, wenn ich Menschen in solche Isolationen
bringe, die eben akustisch, lichtmäßig, in jeglicher Hinsicht deren Außenkontakt verliere.
Auf der einen Seite, manchmal sucht man das,
man möchte gerne isoliert sein von allem, aber auf der anderen Seite,
das halten wir nicht lange durch, wir brauchen diese Inputs von außen und diese,
wir nennen das ja dann auch Deprivation, Dieser Entzug von Informationen ist für uns.
Sehr verstörend und wenn das dann über stunden geht und die raumfahrer in der
raumfahrt geschichte in der raumfahrt medizin waren gerade solche versuche in
solchen kammern oder auch in wasserbädern die mit salz gefüllt haben wo man dann so schön,
Da hat man die mehrere Stunden in diesem, wer darf,
heute wird das angeboten für 50 oder 100 Euro, ich weiß nicht,
hier gibt es auch so ein paar Dinger, um sich dann zu entspannen,
ja gut, okay, entspannen, aber
wenn das zu lang geht, dann will der Körper wissen, woran er Kontakt hat.
Eigentlich für das ja allein sein ist was anderes als sich einsam fühlen das
sind auch zwei verschiedene das eine mag mal ganz nett sein mit sich selber
aber sich einsam fühlen ist dann schon da beginnt schon der Schmerzcharakter.
Sehr interessantes sehr interessantes psychophysiologisches Thema.
Der Mensch als Sensor Netzwerk. Man kommt sich vor wie so ein Krake mit einer Million Arme.
Ja eine Informationskrake die sich dauernd darüber informieren muss was ist hier eigentlich los.
Und so ja das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch die Triebfeder von von Evolution und die Triebfeder von.
Ohne dass ich diese Information kriege, kann ich auch kein Leben gestalten,
zielgerichtet jedenfalls nicht, also dafür haben wir dann ein paar Milliarden
Jahre gebraucht, um das alles zu entwickeln, was da drin ist.
Der Weg hat sich ja dann irgendwann an die Charité geführt, wann kam das dann dazu?
Das kam an die Charité selber, ich war ja vorher an der Freien Universität Berlin
in Dahlem, in der Arnim-Allee, im Physiologischen Institut.
Dann wurde, nachdem Wovereit beschlossen hatte, dass da die Medizin hier neu
geortet werden soll, Da kam die Zusammenlegung der...
Es gab zwei Fakultäten, eine in der Humboldt-Universität und eine in der Freien Universität.
Und die wurden dann zusammengenommen und die haben dann 2003,
2004 das Dach der Charité bekommen.
Deswegen hat auch die Charité als Universität zwei Köpfe. Sie haben sowohl den
Präsidenten von der Humboldt-Universität wie von der Freien Universität.
Das ist ein sehr eigenwilliges Konstrukt, das ist ja keine medizinische Hochschule,
sondern sie ist, das war, was ich sehr gut finde,
ich finde reine medizinische Hochschulen nicht gut,
also ich finde die Anbildung an die Universität finde ich sehr gut,
weil man da immer neue Inputs auch aus Fachgebieten bekommt,
die jetzt nicht direkt etwas mit der Medizin vielleicht zu tun haben,
aber doch irgendwie vielleicht eine Rolle spielen könnten, also
Ich bin ein größerer Befürworter von Studien, die eben auch mal den eigenen Horizont verlassen.
Da vielleicht ist es dann leichter, als wenn man in der medizinischen Hochschule
nur mit Medizin und deren Folgen zu tun hat.
Also diese Zusammenlegung. Und dann wurde eben diese,
wurde eine zunächst Stiftungsprofessur geschaffen,
für Weltraummedizin und Extremumwelten,
wirklich ein Unikat in der sogar europäischen Hochschullandschaft,
nicht nur in der deutschen und da haben sich dann mehrere Personen drauf beworben
und ich habe dann nachher den Zuschlag bekommen.
Und nach den fünf Jahren, das war sozusagen, da war diese Stifter,
die das Geld zur Verfügung gestellt haben, also damals EADS,
ein Raumfahrtkonzern, dann waren es private Stifter, dann war es die jüdischen
Ärzte in Deutschland, und ein Vertreter von denen, der was mitgegeben hat.
Also es war so aus mehreren Teilen auch interessant, eine Stiftung,
die mehrere Mittelgeber hatte, und glücklicherweise hatten sie auch die richtigen
Rechtsanwälte, um dann mit den Universitäten zu verhandeln, damit man danach,
Ich nach den fünf Jahren sagte, okay das war ja nett, sie haben das alles bezahlt,
aber jetzt schauen sie mal wie es draußen aussieht.
Da wurde da so eine Stellhülle gefunden, okay die Professur,
wenn der fünf Jahre rum ist und stellt keine Dummheiten an, dann geht das über in einer Stellnummer.
Wie groß ist das Institut, wie viele Leute sind da so unterwegs?
In dem ganzen Physiologischen Institut sind wir glaube ich 70 Personen,
da ist aber auch sehr viel technisches Personal, da sind andere dabei.
Unsere Arbeitsgruppe sind jetzt acht Leute, die mir speziell zugeteilt sind.
Wir haben ja die normale Ausbildung für die Mediziner auch, also wir beschäftigen
uns jetzt nicht nur mit irgendwelchen Leuten, die durch die Sahara marschieren
oder sonst wo, oder ins All fliegen, sondern wir haben die normale Mediziner
Ausbildung mit zu absolvieren.
Das heißt Kurse, die sich mit Herz-Kreislauf-Atmung beschäftigen.
Das ist ja das, was Physiologie eben ausmacht. die verschiedenen Funktionsweisen
im Körper zu beschreiben.
So extreme Umwelten, also Raum, Weltraum ist klar,
aber was sind denn so die anderen extremen Umwelten,
die sie jetzt im Rahmen dieser Tätigkeit so ins Auge fassen,
wo manifestiert sich sozusagen das Wesen und die Grenzen des Körpers,
was schaut man sich da konkret an?
Eigentlich all die Dinge, die Natur im Wesentlichen ausmachen.
Also das ist auf der einen Seite Veränderung des Trocks, auf der anderen Seite
Veränderungen der Temperatur.
Dann auch, wie gerade angesprochen, auch die Isolation oder Confinement,
das Beengtsein, wenn man in Räumen ist, so ein Übergangsbereich zwischen der
Physiologie und der Psychologie.
Dann eben die Schwerkraft oder dann auch die Ernährung. Wenn sie hier am Wochenende
einen Halbmarathon oder Marathon laufen, da ist die Frage, ist das jetzt ein
energetisches Problem?
Hat er lang genug trainiert? Dann sind sie in der Trainingswissenschaft,
in der Sportwissenschaft.
Also alle Bereiche haben ihren eigenen sozusagen Grenzpunkt,
wenn ich wirklich einen Ausdauer auf mache und nicht genügend trinke,
weil es entsprechend heiß ist, dann wird zum Beispiel die Thermoregulation eine Rolle spielen.
Dann kann er noch sehr viel Energie im Körper haben, aber wenn er zu viel geschwitzt
hat, dann geht der Kreislauf runter, weil er nicht entsprechend hydriert worden ist.
Oder wenn ich sage, ich schaue mir jetzt jemanden an, der tief taucht.
Na gut, der kann alle Nahrungsmittel und alle Energievorräte im Körper haben,
die er braucht, Aber weil der Druck zu hoch ist, führt das dazu,
dass bestimmte Organe...
Eben dann ihre Funktionen nicht mehr so durchführen können aufgrund des höheren
äußeren Drucks und damit Veränderungen zum Beispiel in der Lunge erzeugen,
die dann dazu führen, dass da bestimmte Druckverhältnisse sich verändern und
zum Beispiel eben der Blutkreislauf dann ganz sich auf die Lunge konzentriert
und dann unter Umständen dazu entsprechenden Veränderungen führt.
Oder gehen sie in die Höhe, dann fehlt eben halt Sauerstoff,
ist nicht mehr genügend da, dann muss man neue Zellen produzieren,
die den Sauerstoff transportieren, wie die roten Blutzellen,
die roten Blutkörperchen.
Das machen ja Sportler zum Beispiel, um dann eben eine höhere Leistungsfähigkeit
zu haben, also mehr Sauerstoff im Körper transportieren zu können.
Jede dieser Bereiche wird im Prinzip angesprochen und unsere Aufgabe ist eben auch herauszufinden,
was kann ich erstmal, wo liegt ein möglicher Schaden und wenn ich den erzeuge,
wie kann ich den vielleicht mit entsprechenden Gegenmaßnahmen abmeldern oder
in seiner Ausprägung jedenfalls vielleicht verhindern, dass es zu früh kommt.
Irgendwo ist immer Schluss.
Ich meine, es ist manchmal die Frage, speziell wenn es dann ins Physiologische
geht, warum das im letzten Fall, z.B. Temperaturregulation. Wir haben vielleicht
die nächste Hitzewelle jetzt schon in 2, 3, 4, 5 Wochen.
Da ist eigentlich die Frage, warum stirbt ein Organismus eigentlich,
wenn die Temperatur zu hoch ist?
Warum, wenn wir die Körpertemperatur nur um 3-4 Grad im Körperkern erhöhen,
also von 37 Grad normalerweise auf 40 Grad, das können wir nicht lange durchhalten.
Da stellt sich die Frage für den Physiologen, warum ist das eigentlich so?
Was ist der mögliche Auslöser, das dann dazu führt, dass wir nicht mehr lebensfähiger
werden? Das kann der Kreislauf sein.
Es kann aber auch zum Beispiel in der Biochemie sein, weil bestimmte Prozesse
zum Beispiel im Energiestoffwechsel, die haben ganz verschiedene Enzyme,
die müssen genau aufeinander abgestimmt sein, wie so eine Lieferkette.
Wir hatten das Problem mit den Chips in diesen früheren Autos.
Das ganze Auto kann fertig sein, aber wenn ich irgendwo nicht den Chip habe,
der das Ding jetzt vom Zünder anfällt, dann bleibt die ganze Kiste stehen.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass bei hohen Temperaturen zum Beispiel in dieser Kette,
die man biochemisch zum Beispiel zum Zersetzen von Nahrung, wenn ich einen Kohlehydrat
oder einen Fett habe, dann gibt es verschiedenste Enzyme, die müssen da das
Zeug so klein molekular zerhacken.
Die haben alle irgendwo ein sogenanntes Optimum ihrer Temperatur,
diese bestimmten Stoffe.
Und wenn jetzt einer dieser Schritte vielleicht eine andere Temperatur braucht
oder eine Genauigkeit, dann kann es sein, dass da das Ding ausfällt.
Dann habe ich aber da hinten auch kein richtiges Protein mehr,
dass das nächste steuert.
Und das kann dazu führen, dass zum Beispiel eine einfache Temperaturerhöhung
um drei Grad dazu führt, dass ein Organismus darunter stirbt.
Deswegen haben wir so viele Abwehrmechanismen.
Wenn es heiß ist, wir fangen an zu schwitzen, wir erhöhen die Hautdurchblutung,
wir machen uns auf, schnell möglichst was zu trinken,
möglichst nicht viel zu essen, weil das dann zusätzlich unsere Durchblutung im Darm erhöht,
das wollen wir nicht haben in dem Augenblick, also es sind verschiedenste Mechanismen,
die alle darauf achten, dass wir bloß diese 37 Grad da,
Kleidung, scharfes Essen essen, Es gibt Verhaltensweisen und in extremen Umwelten
ist meistens das Verhalten das entscheidend, ob sie da überleben oder sich nicht richtig verhalten.
So groß sind unsere physiologischen Anpassungsmöglichkeiten nicht.
Das Verhalten ist das entscheidende. Wenn es heiß ist, gehe ich halt manchmal
an die Sachen. Dann wird eben die Hecke nicht geschnitten.
Oder ich laufe eben nicht 25 Kilometer. Muss ich ja in der Regel nicht.
Bleiben wir mal bei der Temperatur, weil wir da jetzt schon so rangegangen sind
und gucken noch mal kurz auf die extremen Welten, wo das jetzt sozusagen eine Rolle spielt.
Wir hatten den Sport, ganz klar, aber natürlich generell Wetter oder wo man
halt so wohnt spielt natürlich generell eine Rolle, gar keine Frage.
Das heißt, in Ländern wo es generell heißer ist, haben die Körper dann eben
auch selbst entsprechende Gegenmaßnahmen sich herbei evolutioniert oder sind
es eher Verhaltensweisen?
Das sind Verhaltensweisen. Das ist dann vielleicht auch häufig so ein bisschen
so ein Irrtum nach dem Motto, also die da im Sahara oder in anderen Wüstenbereichen,
die können dann eine höhere Temperatur haben.
Ne ne ne nix, die haben auch ihre 37 Grad die sie einhalten müssen.
Da ist es das Verhalten, dass ich bestimmte Bekleidung habe,
dass ich mich zu bestimmten Zeiten nur herausbewege, also es ist eine Verhaltensanpassung.
Ich meine wenn sie über 40 Grad haben, Lufttemperatur vielleicht auch noch verbunden
mit einer hohen Luftfeuchtigkeit, das ist für den Körper nicht so aushalten.
Aber Hautfarbe mag eine Rolle spielen.
Ja genau, das sind dann so spezielle Anpassungen, die zum Beispiel dann eben davor schützen,
dass man bei zu hoher UV-Belastung oder Strahlung eben halt keine Zellschädigung erleidet,
wie jetzt meinetwegen Hammer-Irre, der da nach Australien auswandert,
der hat da ein Problem, weil der hat eben zu wenig von den Zellschädigungen.
Ich kenn das, ich hab auch so ein paar britische Gene, das ist nicht so schön im Sommer.
Hat aber den großen Vorteil, dass man eben halt in diesen Bereichen,
wo es weniger Licht hat, besseres Knochenwachstum hat.
Also wenn Sie jemanden nehmen, der nur dunkle Hautfarbe hat und bringen den
in die nordischen Bereiche,
dann hat der durchaus Probleme nachher genügend, weil wir über die Haut dann
eine bestimmte Aktivierung von Hormonen brauchen, die dann dazu führen,
dass sie Calcium zum Beispiel einladen.
Die haben dann Schwierigkeiten damit. Wenn jemand aus den Bereichen kommt,
aus den Tropen in die Arktis geht, andersrum in der Regel haben diejenigen,
die in tropischen Bereichen leben und schon mehrere zehntausend Jahre leben,
die haben eine höhere Schweißproduktion.
Ja und die Schweißzusammensetzung ist dann adaptiert, wie man sagt,
die hat sich angepasst, da sind dann weniger Elektrolyte drin.
Also wenn wir jetzt hier aus dem Urlaub da runterfahren und uns da unten irgendwie so begeben,
dass wir ordentlich schwitzen, dann verlieren wir relativ viel Elektrolyte,
also Salze, die in diesem Schweiß sind, Natrium, Kalium, Magnesium,
Kalzium, die gehen dann leider verloren.
Bei denjenigen, die da jetzt länger unten sind, da wird sehr viel von dem vor
dem Schwitzen zurück resorbiert.
Der Körper lässt das gar nicht erst raus, sondern der holt sich diese Substanz
und kann dann übrigens auch noch physikalisch leichter schwitzen.
Je weniger Salz da drin sind, umso leichter kann man schwitzen.
Verdunsten und durch das Verdunsten erzeugen sie Kälte.
Da geht Energie mit dem Körper entzogen und das ist sehr viel Energie.
Also ein Liter Schweiß macht ungefähr 560 Kilokalorien, also ein Drittel des
Energiebedarfs, den man pro
Tag überhaupt hat in Ruhe. Können Sie dadurch bei einem Liter Schweiß...
Steckt man in Schweiß?
Ja, den steckt man in den Schweiß und damit wird der weggeführt,
abgeführt und kann dadurch den Körper auf seinen 37 Grad halten.
Und das ist evolutionär wahrscheinlich eine der entscheidendsten Veränderungen,
die wir in einer Optimierung zur Ausdauerfähigkeit in der Evolution bekommen haben.
Also diese Fähigkeit zu schwitzen ermöglicht uns sehr lange Strecken mit nicht
allzu hoher aber doch ganz guter Geschwindigkeitslaufen.
Wenn wir evolutionär sozusagen auf der Jagd waren früher,
dann hat das sicherlich einen enormen Vorteil gehabt, dass wir schwitzen konnten,
denn dann kann man auch Tiere, die schneller sind, aber dadurch entsprechend
erlegen, dass man denen dauernd folgt, bis sie dann eben halt tatsächlich in
eine Situation kommen, wo sie für uns greifbar gewesen sind,
also es ist ein erheblicher Vorteil.
Wir haben ja auch das Haarkleid verloren, was man dann auch nicht so gerne hat,
man will ja nicht nur in die Haare eingepackt sein, sondern man möchte gerne schwitzen.
Andere Organismen die das nicht haben, haben da ein Problem,
die überhitzen alles sehr schnell.
Ja Mensch der Superjäger sozusagen, das ist eine Fähigkeit. Laufen, das können wir.
Ja, war doch einer dieser, ich glaube, Sattobek hat das mal gesagt,
Fisch schwimmen, Vogel fliehen, Mensch läuft.
So kann man es kurz zusammenfassen. Gut beobachtet, ja.
Erklärt auch, warum man in heißen Regionen häufiger so salzhaltige Getränke
zu sich neigert und Lassi etc.
Ja, dann wird da substituiert sozusagen, was auf der anderen Seite eben mehr
verloren geht und das schränkt dann nach einer gewissen Zeit halt unsere Leistungsfähigkeit
auch da wieder ein, da kommen wir auch wieder an eine Grenze ran.
Also diese Grenzen und da ist eben dann wiederum die Ausgangsfrage,
was, wo, an welcher Stelle bricht diese Kette am Erden zuerst.
Da ist es dann eben nicht unbedingt die Energie zuvor. Wir haben immer noch
irgendwo ein kleines Fettpolster, was sonst aussieht.
Man könnte es auch mal so zusammenfassen, um Ihre Ausgangsfrage auch nochmal
zu beantworten, was extreme Umwelten sind.
Wenn Sie sieben Minuten keinen Sauerstoff haben, dann sterben Ihre Hirnzellen
ab. Also Sauerstoff ist das Entscheidende. Ohne den kommen Sie nicht aus.
Sie können sieben Tage ungefähr ohne Wasser leben als Erwachsener.
Wenn sie Wien verschüttet, dann haben Leute da in der Türkei und Syrien,
da können sie auch manchmal 10 Tage oder 11 Tage, da müssen sie aber in dieser
Hinsicht günstige Umgebungsbedingungen haben.
Aber sie können in der Regel, wenn sie auch nicht sehr viel an Übergewicht haben,
sieben Wochen können sie hungern.
Also man sieht schon, der Sauerstoff ist wichtig, der Wasserbedarf ist wichtig
und der Energiehaushalt.
Aber jeder hat so seine eigene Zeitachse.
Zum Essen kommen wir vielleicht gleich nochmal. Ich würde gerne noch bei der Temperatur bleiben.
Große Wärme hatten wir jetzt schon, aber es gibt ja auch das andere Extrem. Ja, wir kühlen.
Es gibt aber auch kalte Zonen auf diesem Planeten.
Hat man schon von gehört ja, leben ja auch einige Leute und auch sehr spektakulär,
wenn man sich das so anschaut, welche Kulturtechniken dort entwickelt wurden,
um damit irgendwie klar zu kommen, so was Kleidung betrifft, Hausbau etc.
Gehört ja alles mit dazu. Aber inwiefern haben sie das untersucht,
wie fährt man dann da hin?
Schaut man sich das an, untersucht man die Leute vor Ort oder steckt man einfach
Leute in die Kühlbox ins Labor und macht Kabel dran und sagt,
ist egal es sind nur zwei Stunden.
Ja es kommt auf die Fragestellung an, im Labor kann ich eben Sachen sehr sehr
gut kontrollieren, wenn ich zum Beispiel sehen möchte, welche Bekleidung ist
besonders effektiv, die Körpertemperatur zu halten, Wärmeabgabe zu messen etc.
Dafür gibt es solche Klimakammern.
Da kann ich also sehr kontrollierte Ausmittelungen, aber die geben mir natürlich
nicht eine natürliche Umgebung, in der ihr jetzt arbeitet oder wie wir zum Beispiel
eine Untersuchung haben in der Antarktis, bei den Leuten, die da auf der deutschen
Antarktis-Station sind.
Und ich hatte auch Gelegenheit in meinem Berufsleben da unten mal vorbeizufahren für mehrere Wochen,
um zu sehen, wie die dort arbeiten und was für Probleme die halt haben und wie
wirkt sich das aus, dass sie dann auf so einer Station da leben müssen.
Da kommt man dann nicht herum, dass man sich das vor Ort anschaut.
Also beim Menschen ist es wichtig, ihre Bemerkungen, die sie gemacht haben, erstmal zu beobachten.
Großen vorgefertigten Hypothesen, wie das normalerweise in der Wissenschaft
ist, also die man hier am Schreibtisch entwickelt und dachte,
das muss jetzt so sein und wenn die die Temperatur so haben,
dann wird das hilft dir eigentlich in der Regel wenig.
Was du mitnehmen musst, du musst erst mal die anschauen, wie leben die dort,
wo treten die Probleme auf und die Probleme sind meistens völlig,
zunächst scheinbar völlig belanglos. Ich erinnere mich an eine Situation da
in der Antarktis, in dem allgemeinen Aufenthaltsraum.
Da gab es zum Beispiel Ärger, weil jemand irgendwie den Stift,
den irgendjemand da hatte an seinem Arbeitsplatz, immer irgendwo anders hingelegt hat.
Das war nachher das Problem. Ja, darüber haben die sich geköppelt.
Nicht, dass da draußen minus 30 Grad sind oder so, sondern es war die Situation
psychologisch, der hat ihnen fünfmal gesagt, hier, das ist mein Ding hier,
das ist mein Platz hier, das schon wieder irgendjemand hat hingenommen oder
irgendjemand hat hingenommen.
Oder die Zahnbürste, die nicht andere... Solche Sachen sind dann auf einmal
und das ist das, was man als Forscher machen muss, beobachten.
Am besten so einfach ein Bleistift, Papier, ein Feldbuch, ähnlich wie so ein
Geologe, der sich eine Zeichnung macht über irgendeinen Aufschluss oder so.
Erstmal beschreiben, was sind da wo, treten Konfliktpunkte auf,
was belastet die Leute wirklich.
Heute zum Beispiel, wenn sie Kälte haben, heute haben sie so ausgefuchste Bekleidungsstücke,
da kann es draußen minus 50 Grad sein, dann haben sie immer noch Kälte.
Eher das Problem, dass es dann unter Umständen, wenn sie körperlich arbeiten, zu warm daran wird.
Aber der Mensch ist wirklich nur das eine, es gibt natürlich auch andere Organismen
und wenn man da die extreme Umwelt betrachtet, dann muss man sich auch mal fragen,
in welchem Lebenszyklus betrachten wir auch das Leben.
Das ist nämlich auch noch interessant. Wir reden im Augenblick nur von Erwachsenen.
Wenn sie einen Organismus haben, der sich erst formt, wie eine Kaulquapp oder
so etwas, dann hat die eine ganz
andere Temperaturempfindlichkeit als eine ausgewachsene Kröte oder Frosch.
Oder dasselbe ist bei Menschen, wenn ich Kleinkinder habe, reagieren die anders
als ein Pubertierender oder einer der 60 oder 70 Jahre. Es kommt also auch auf
den Lebenszyklus an, in dem ich den Organismus betrachten will.
Und das finde ich hochinteressant, wenn Sie sich das mal genau angucken im Leben.
Da werden Sie sehen, dass 99% der Organismen, die auf diesem Planeten leben,
die können nicht überleben bei Temperaturen für den gesamten Lebenszyklus bei über 45 Grad.
Oder bei 32 Grad und darunter.
Also in einer Spanne von 6 bis 7 Grad da spielt sich im Prinzip das Leben ab.
Es gibt einzelne Formen die sich dann als Sporen oder so als halbgefroren oder
so etwas überleben können. Aber um wirklich aktiv zu sein, ein aktives Leben
zu haben, das ist eine Spannbreite von 7 Grad.
Das ist unglaublich gering.
Man hätte ja auch meinen können, die Evolution hat in den drei Milliarden Jahren
ein bisschen größeres Spektrum geschaffen,
aber die hängen alle, die ganzen Lebensverhältnisse hängen alle so miteinander so verdraht,
dass können sie nicht auf einmal sagen, gerade im Hinblick auf die Erderwärme,
wo man sagt, okay dann passen wir uns eben an, dann ist es halt ein bisschen
wärmer und dann ist auch unser Körper ein bisschen wärmer und damit läuft das
halt. Das läuft doch nicht, da ist zappenduster.
Das ist die Spanne in der dieser Leben entsprechend.
Gibt's da ne schlüssige Erklärung für diesen Sweetspot?
Also ich meine wir hatten das ja schon tangiert, dass bestimmte Proteine einfach
nur in so einem speziellen energetischen Zustand überhaupt funktionieren.
Ja, aber es geht jetzt hier um die Spanne, denn interessanterweise diesen Schlüssel,
den wir da erwähnt hatten mit dem sogenannten Intermediärstoffwechsel,
also der beim Abbau eines Stoffes der im Körper jetzt in ein anderes Protein
zum Beispiel jetzt gebildet werden.
Diese Kette, die wie gesagt hat sehr unterschiedliche Temperaturen und das interessante ist,
früher hat man gedacht okay diese 45 Grad das ist jetzt deswegen weil da anfangen
die Proteine zu denaturieren,
also die verändern so ein Protein hat eine bestimmte Strukturbauweise und wenn
es dann zu warm ist dann geht diese Bauweise eben halt bricht da und dann ist
das Ding nicht mehr funktionsfähig.
Klingt erstmal plausibel, das kann man im Reagenzglas beobachten,
es ist aber nicht ganz stichhaltig, wenn man sich jetzt interessanterweise anguckt, z.B.
Organismen, die immer in der Kälte leben, wie so ein Eisfisch.
Ein Eisfisch, der oben im Nordatlantik lebt, der lebt bei einer Wassertemperatur
um 0 Grad oder 1 Grad minus oder 2 Grad minus.
Können die, weil die so ne Art von Frostschutzmittel da in ihrem Körper haben.
Aber die haben auch nur 6 Grad. Wenn sie so einen Eis-Fisch jetzt in ein warmes Wasser setzen...
Bis sechs Grad hält er das aus, also die sechs Grad Temperaturspann hält er
aus, aber wenn es sieben, acht oder neun Grad ist, dann stirbt auch dieser Organismus.
Weil der Organismus dafür gebaut ist, in dieser kalten Umgebung genau diese
mittleren Temperaturen zu erzeugen?
Ja, weil dann ist das spricht eher dafür, dass was mit dem Intermediärstoff
wechselt, also dass diese wie gesagt diese Kette dann durchbrochen wird,
wenn da größere Temperaturschritte gemacht werden.
Wenn es jetzt, denn ein Protein das ist denaturiert bei sechs Grad,
das ist eigentlich relativ unwahrscheinlich.
Aber herrschen denn in dem Fisch normale Temperaturen?
Der hat die Temperatur von diesen ein, zwei, drei Grad. Der ganze Fisch?
Der ganze Fisch, ja. Also es ist nicht so, dass er in der Mitte so einen kleinen
Reaktor hat? Nein, nein, nein.
Es gibt andere Fische, die so viel haben und dann eine höhere Temperatur haben.
Aber das heißt es gibt dann doch Proteine, die in anderen Temperaturbereichen
auch lebenserreichenden Fruchtstoff haben?
Ja, aber das Denaturieren beruht ja darauf, dass man sagt, okay dieses Protein
wird geknackt, weil wir eine zu hohe Temperatur haben.
Wir knacken normalerweise Proteine bei 45 Grad aufwärts. 50 Grad fallen die
Dinger auseinander und dann ist es raus. Aber wenn tatsächlich jetzt ein Protein
bei 6 Grad kann das nicht denaturieren. Das ist...
Mehr als unwahrscheinlich, die Struktur wird nicht so verändert.
Es ist aber offensichtlich so, dass eben diese verschiedenen Abhängigkeiten,
um dann ein Protein, dass da die Temperatur eine Rolle spielt.
Nicht jetzt im Einzelfall für das Protein was da geknackt wird,
sondern der Weg dahin wird geknackt.
Das ist wie als wenn verschiedene Türen sozusagen müssen erst geöffnet werden.
Und da ist eben das interessante daran ist, dass man auf diese Spur gekommen
ist beim Fisch, der jetzt eiskalt ist und nicht bei einer Untersuchung bei 45
Grad sich irgendwelche Organismen angeguckt hat, die da besonders warm sind.
Die Argumentationslinie ist also genau umgedreht aus diesem,
da haben wir Eisfischerforschung herausgekommen, okay das mit den 45 Grad könnte
auch eine andere, könnte eine Folge sein von vorher ablaufenden Dingen.
Gibt's dann irgendwie, ich meine es ist ja im wesentlichen,
also diese ganze Betrachtung von, es gibt so ein Temperaturbereich in dem funktioniert
jetzt der Mensch und die allermeisten anderen Lebewesen und es gibt so ein paar
Extreme und die funktionieren nochmal anders aus anderen Gründen.
Gibt es eine physikalisch chemische Erklärung warum ein Großteil dieser Proteine
die für uns Leben ausmachen dann ausgerechnet in diesem Bereich aufhören zu funktionieren?
Oder ist es einfach nur so weil die Temperaturen bei uns auf der Erde eben nun
mal so sind wie sie sind, haben wir uns den Satz an Proteinen für unser Leben quasi erworben?
Daraus sind wir so heraus evolutioniert, weil das war halt das was so gut funktioniert
hat. Hätten wir jetzt höhere Temperaturen, gibt es vielleicht andere Proteinstrukturen,
die sich erst noch bilden oder die so nie zum Leben herangezogen wurden,
die wir dann quasi wo wir uns hin evolutionieren können.
Interessante Frage, ich meine,
wenn wir uns die Entwicklungsgeschichte des Lebens anschauen, dann...
Sind ja wahrscheinlich die ersten schritte des lebens eigentlich in sehr heißen
bereichen also solchen vulkanen ja es spricht einiges dafür dass dort entsprechende
chemische verbindungen gebildet werden können aufgrund.
Der hohen Temperaturen und des reichhaltigen Mineralgehaltes in diesen Hotspots, die da sind.
Das heißt, diese Organismen, diese Zellen, gibt es auch einzelne Schutzmechanismen.
Die produzieren zum Beispiel bestimmte sogenannte Heat Shock Proteins.
Proteine, die die Zelle davor schützen. Die Zelle ist ja sozusagen auch für
uns die grundlegende Funktionsstruktur,
also die Einheit, die musste erst mal gebildet werden, die sich abkapseln kann
von der Umgebung um ein eigenes Biotop zu schaffen.
Also jede Zellmembran ist auch, wenn man so will, eine Abkapselung von dieser
Welt und die müssen wir erst mal bilden.
Und als das gebildet worden ist, offensichtlich, wenn man in die Bereiche kommt,
in denen meistens so eine Temperatur herrscht, in der sich Organismen dann entsprechend aufhalten,
Die hat jetzt dazu geführt, dass wir offensichtlich einen Satz von chemischen
Strukturen entsprechend zerlegen können mit der entsprechenden Effizienz.
Dieser in diesem Temperaturabschnitt und alle anderen die da rausgehen sind
halt offensichtlich schwerer und anfälliger sonst hätte sich da ein größerer
Horizont aufgetan aber das ist für diesen Planeten ist das offensichtlich und
deswegen müssen wir halt mit dem Klima auch aufpassen weil wir sind nichts für was anderes gebaut.
Wie ist das überhaupt zu erklären, dass wir eigentlich uns ja zumindest in diesen Breiten,
es ist ja nicht 36 Grad warm, sondern das ist ja für uns schon eine anstrengende
Temperatur, sondern wir mögen es ja eigentlich eher kälter, brauchen aber im
Körper so eine Betriebstemperatur.
Gibt es eine schlüssige Erklärung dafür warum wir uns sozusagen nochmal einen
höheren Wärmeort selber permanent schaffen und dafür ja auch Energie aufwenden müssen,
wenn man, warum ist es dann auf einmal unangenehm, wenn es wärmer wird,
also im Mittel ist es halt so.
Wir, das heißt die Inspirons, die Säugetiere, haben in der Regel so 37 Grad,
plus, minus, ein, zwei, drei, zwei Grad. Das ist sehr eng für die Säugetiere.
Das hat natürlich den riesigen evolutionären Vorteil, dass wir permanent aktiv
sein können. Ich meine, wenn sie so eine arme Eidechse sind,
die muss ich erstmal in die Sonne legen, damit die ordentlich auf Fahrt kommt.
Die Muskulatur der Stoffe, der braucht eben halt eine höhere Betriebstemperatur.
Der Vorteil so einer Echse oder so einer Schlange, eines Reptils ist halt,
dass sie sehr sehr lange mit relativ wenig Nahrung auskommen.
Ich meine so eine Schlange, wenn die mal irgendwas gefressen hat,
dann kann die auch mal ein halbes Jahr hungern. Das macht für die gar nichts.
Wir brauchen, um unsere Betriebstemperatur sehr hoch zu halten,
permanent entsprechende Energiezufuhr.
Das ist ein Problem. Das wird zum Problem, je mehr wir halt,
das sieht man ja in dieser Welt, je mehr wir Menschen haben,
die alle etwas zu essen haben müssen.
Wenn wir mehrere Milliarden sind, wird das allein die Beschaffung und die Verteilung
zu einem gewissen Problem.
Wenn wir eine relativ beschränkte Anzahl sind, ist das weniger ein Problem.
Aber es ist sozusagen der große Vorteil ist wir sind zu eigentlich zu allen
Tages- und Nachtzeiten mehr oder weniger können wir aktiv sein,
weil wir die Temperaturhaltung haben.
Das kann man erstmal als evolutionären Vorteil beschreiben.
Damit sind wir ja eigentlich schon beim nächsten Block so ein bisschen,
nämlich diese Frage eben der Energie.
Also wir sind ja nur so permanente Reaktoren und versuchen uns so,
ja beschicken wir uns sozusagen mit Treibstoff und grad so dieses hungern und
fasten oder überfressen,
Ist ja auch immer so ein heißes Thema, wir sind ja alle sehr dick geworden,
weil wir so viel Nahrung hier haben, im Westen zumindest,
und der ganze Energiehaushalt ist nochmal eine andere Frage,
aber was sind denn sozusagen die Grenzen des Körpers jetzt,
wenn eben so ein Nahrungszustrom in irgendeiner Form unterbrochen ist oder eingeschränkt
ist, also woraus zehren wir und wie lange können wir denn daraus zehren?
Also ein halbes Jahr schaffen wir jetzt nicht wie die Schlange, aber was geht denn?
Nehmen wir einfach mal einen 70 Kilogramm schweren Mann, der erwachsen ist,
dann hat der ungefähr 30 Kilogramm Muskulatur und ungefähr, schätze mal, 10 Kilogramm Fett.
Und dann hat er in dieser Muskulatur noch bestimmte Speicher,
insbesondere ein bisschen in der Leber, wo er direkt Kohlenhydrate,
also Zucker, speichern kann, wenn man so will.
Zucker in der Leber sind das ungefähr 100-150 Gramm, die wir da an Zucker speichern,
an Kohlenhydraten, und 350 Gramm in der Muskulatur, also ungefähr 500 Gramm haben wir.
500 Gramm, das ist energetisch, ein Gramm Kohlenhydrate, ein Gramm Zucker,
wenn man so will, hat 4 Kilokalorien, also wenn wir 500 Gramm haben,
mal 4 sind 2000 Kilokalorien.
Das ist gerade das, was wir, wenn wir mehr oder weniger gerade mal ein bisschen
in Ruhe tätig sind, pro Tag brauchen. Also wir haben im Prinzip Prodehydrate
als Speicher für einen Tag.
Die müssen wir immer wieder aufwenden, deswegen haben wir auch einen hohen Appetit,
wenn es zum Beispiel auf Zucker oder süße Sachen geht. Das ist ein begrenzter Stoff.
Beim Fett jetzt, wenn wir 10 Kilogramm Fett haben, 10 Kilogramm,
das sind also 10.000 Gramm.
1 Kilogramm, 1000 Gramm, 10 Kilo, 10.000 Gramm. 1 Gramm Fett hat nun eine Energiedichte
von rund 10 Kilokalorien.
Das sind ein bisschen weniger als 9, aber das ist leichter zu rechnen.
Das heißt, wenn wir 10 kg Fett haben im Körper, dann haben wir 10.000 g Fett mal 10 kg Fett.
Kilokalorien. Dann haben wir 100.000 Kilokalorien.
Also hundertzig mal so viel.
Genau. Also das heißt 50 Tage können wir im Prinzip bei 2000 Kilokalorien,
können wir 50 Tage rein, jetzt theoretisch, davon leben. Dann haben wir jetzt noch Muskelmasse.
Nun gut, die kann man auch noch verstoffwechseln. Das tut der Körper,
wenn er extrem viel Hunger hat, dann geht er auch an die Muskelmasse.
Ich meine, Sie können keinen Herzmuskelverstoff wechseln. Aber sie können dann eben Extremitäten,
die Arme werden dünn, das was man teilweise auch bei älteren Personen dann schon
beobachtet, dass sie dann ihren Muskelmasse abbauen und diese Proteine auch
als Energiereserve nehmen.
Oder wenn eben halt sie in Regionen gehen, wo sie im Hunger leiden,
dann sehen sie diese dünnen Beine, Da wird sozusagen das Wenige,
was sie haben, was für die Bewegung noch da ist, wird auch wieder evolutionär
versucht, den Körper noch mit etwas zu versorgen.
Dann baut der Muskelmasse ab. Da haben sie auch noch mal gut und gerne vielleicht 10, 15 Tage.
Also wenn man genau hinguckt, wir haben für einen Tag Kohlehydrate,
Zucker, als Energieschränkung, muss also permanent neu zugeführt werden.
Das kann man über Biochemische.
50 Tage mit Fett und die meisten Leute haben ja nicht das Problem,
dass sie 10 Kilogramm haben, sondern sie haben eher vielleicht 50 Kilogramm.
Könnten also lange überleben.
Ja.
Aber das heißt doch jetzt nicht, dass ich problemlos lange Hunger...
Es ist halt begrenzt, aber man sieht ja, es kommt immer auf die Zeitachse an,
akut haben wir da kein Problem mit, aber wenn ich jetzt irgendwo havariere in ihrem Boot,
dann können sie davon ausgehen, dass sie nach zwei,
drei Tagen wird sich der Hunger mächtig steigern, das ist auch klar,
Werden Enzyme, werden bestimmte Hormone hochgefahren, die ihr Hungergefühl maximal stressen.
Auch so, dass sie nach ein paar Tagen schon, wenn sie mit einem anderen Kollegen
im Boot gelandet sind, den vielleicht ganz anders angucken.
Alles schon beschrieben worden. Das dauert nur ein paar Tage.
Also da ist auch unsere zivilisatorische Rechtsgrundlage kommt da relativ schnell ins Schwanken.
Und es gibt die ein oder anderen Schilderungen, die ja auch bekannt sind in
den Flugzeugen, wo in den Anden abgestürzt sind und so weiter, die man kennt.
Diese Quellen sind natürlich für uns Extremphysiologen.
Das jetzt bitte richtig verstehen interessant in dem sinne dass man das kann
man natürlich nicht experimentell und so untersuchen aber man kann natürlich
aus den erfahrungen die diese menschen haben und wie sie das beschreiben,
kann man die ein oder anderen rückschlüsse ziehen in welchem zeitgang spielt
sich so etwas ab das ist auch zum beispiel schilderung also nach drei oder vier
tagen wie gesagt ist dann besonders starkes hungergefühl,
Was dann auch zu entsprechenden Konflikten führt, dann flacht das im Prinzip
ab, aber dann geht der Körper auch in so ein bisschen so ein Dämmerzustand über,
wenn man gar nichts mehr ist. Und dann so nach dem 20.
Tag, dann geht das wieder hoch. 20. 25. so so so.
Geht das wieder hoch, die Aufmerksamkeit?
Ja ja, das Hungergefühl und jetzt der Drang das irgendwie zu lösen.
Und irgendwie meine ich wirklich so wie ich sage irgendwie zu lösen und das
ist dann gerade eben für Gruppen oder so etwas ist dann dann unter Umständen
eine schwierige Geschichte.
Und die englische Seefahrer Nation hatte dafür dann auch ein eigenes,
Eigene Handhabung, da gab es kein gerechtes, das nannte sich Law of the Sea.
Die haben dann tatsächlich, wenn sie in diese Havarie-Situation gekommen sind,
dann haben die dann Hölzstäbchen gezogen, wer den koffert.
Das war ein ungeschriebenes Gesetz, bis ich glaube so 1880 ungefähr,
Dann wurde es mal gerichtlich geklärt in einem berühmten Rechtsstreit,
ob das denn stadthaft ist, dass man jemanden tötet, um selber zu überleben.
Und es ist dann herausgekommen, dass das nicht stadthaft ist.
Und dann wurde daraus dieses damals übliche Law of the Sea geändert.
Normalerweise wurden die Seefahrer dann vorher nicht angeklagt,
wenn sie das nachweislich,
wenn ein bestimmtes Schema auch eingehalten wurde, also mussten alle zustimmen,
das ist auch so, in diesem Verfahren zum Beispiel,
die mussten alle bei Bewusstsein sein, also es waren schon so ein paar Rahmenbedingungen
gegeben, damit dieses Law of the Sea auch entsprechend angewendet werden durfte.
Wie ist denn das so wenn Leute fasten? Das ist ja auch so ein Ding,
also manche versprechen sich ja davon,
die Erkenntnisse, weiß ich nicht,
mentale Stärkung, es hat halt auch so im islamischen Bereich,
hat es ja auch so eine kulturelle Bedeutung sich so diesem Entzug hinzugeben
und so weiter, auch wenn es ja sozusagen nur tagsüber ist in dem Sinne,
aber ist das eigentlich in irgendeiner Form mal, haben sie das mal untersucht?
Also ist das sozusagen etwas.
Gibt es da ein Bedürfnis sowas zu machen oder ist das wieder so etwas,
was wir uns haben so einfallen lassen, bringt es irgendwas, schadet es in irgendeiner
Form, ist eigentlich egal, also ist so selbstgewählter Hungerentzug irgendwie
mit Einlauf und dann geht es ja erstmal ein paar Tage.
Ja und dann nimmt man in der Regel ja relativ schnell wieder zu,
wenn man was abnehmen wollte, also ehrlich gesagt, ich habe bisher noch keinen getroffen,
der, wenn er so eine Fastenkur gemacht hat, danach sein Gewicht gehalten hat,
sondern in der Regel kommen die alle wieder darauf zurück, also ich habe aber
selber in dem Bereich jetzt nicht untersucht, ich habe mich natürlich mit dem Thema beschäftigt.
Es gibt eine Reihe von Untersuchungen dazu, wiederum kommt man aus dem Bereich
der Evolution und der Evolutionsforschung,
da ist es sicherlich richtig, uns stehen nicht permanent Nahrungsmittel zur Verfügung.
Und eine sozusagen Intermediär, also mit Zeitabschnitten, ist wahrscheinlich
eher der natürliche Zustand gewesen und nicht die permanente Verflüchtbarkeit.
Insofern ist so eine willentlich hergeführte Fasten etwas, was naturgemäß sicherlich aufgetreten ist.
Aber es ist natürlich was vollkommen anderes, wenn ich bewusst auf Nahrung verzichte,
Als wenn ich durch eine Situation dazu gedungen bin, keine Nahrung zu haben.
Das sind zwei völlig verschiedene Sachen.
Wenn ich faste, habe ich dadurch tatsächlich eine mentale Stärkung,
indem ich sage, ich habe eine gewisse Kontrolle über meinen Körper.
Wenn ich aber da irgendwo im Boot sitze und habe nichts zu essen,
dann wird mir das mächtig auf den Zahn gehen, weil das eigentlich nicht mein
Wunsch ist. Weil es auch nicht gerade um Kontrolle geht.
Ich habe die Kontrolle nicht darüber. Hier ist die Frage, in der Tat,
habe ich die Kontrolle über die Situation, dann ist das was anderes,
deswegen hat es sich auch gezeigt, weil das...
Dieses aktive moment ist ja das jene was auch
personen die in den hunger streik gehen entsprechend nach außen bringen dass
sie sozusagen indem ich keine nahrung zu mir führe setze ich natürlich den anderen
auch unter druck dass mir was passieren könnte aber ich mache das ganz bewusst mit einem ziel.
Nämlich, dass ich irgendeine Forderung oder irgendeine Rechtschöpfung erwarte,
die mir bisher vorenthalten wird und die ich damit unter Druck setzen möchte.
Das ist für Außenstehende dann, kann man das nur zunächst beobachten,
aber es bringt natürlich mit jedem Tag der Uhr eine gewisse Gefährdung für diese
Person und damit auch für das System, das offensichtlich eine irgendwie geartete
Handlung nicht vollzieht.
Und mit jedem Tag erhöhe ich den Druck. Aber es ist auch klar,
es ist eine von der Person willentlich herbeigeführte Situation und deswegen teilweise haben die ja,
wenn ich nur denke an die irischen Freiheitskämpfer, die da mehrere 70 oder
80 Tage haben, die gehungert, da ist dann sehr viel auch emotional, ...
Als Stärkung sozusagen so einen Zustand zu überleben, den man vielleicht in
einer normalen Situation halt nicht überlebt hätte.
Also da kommt, es gab ja auch einige Hungerkünstler in unserer Geschichte,
gerade hier in Berlin sind ja so vor 100 Jahren gab es mehrere Hungerkünstler,
die sich dann in welche Gasthöfe gesetzt haben,
in gläsernen Käfig und dann 30 oder 40 Tage gehungert haben und da kamen zehntausende
vorbei und haben sie angeguckt wie die leute da gehungert haben in diesen diesen
kisten die hunger künstler.
Die sich dann dafür haben bezahlen lassen.
Genau die haben dafür eintritt genommen dass sie man dann entsprechend die hatten
daraus ein broterwerb gemacht die hunger künstler.
Da kommt der begriff her.
Dieses, ich versuche mich gerade händeringend an so ein Detail zu erinnern,
was ich meine darüber wahrgenommen zu haben, aber mir fällt es gerade noch mal
nicht ein, aber dieses, die Nahrung kommt nicht regelmäßig.
Ich meine ich hab mal einen Bericht gesehen über so verbliebene Naturvölker in Afrika,
die also traditionell noch mit der Jagd sozusagen ihr Essen beziehen.
Ja die Kunden, die Kunden oder der Kalahari zum Beispiel ist so ein Naturvolk.
Genau, ich weiß es wie gesagt nicht mehr genau, da kam das auch zur Sprache,
dass es halt für sie normal ist einfach mehrere Tage kein Essen zu haben,
ich weiß jetzt bloß nicht mehr genau was so die Schlussfolgerung daraus war,
aber das ist ja dann sozusagen auch ein Zustand, also weiß man,
ob bei diesen Völkern da physiologisch irgendwas anderes abläuft,
dann wenn sie dann Essen haben, dass es irgendwie anders war,
aufgenommen wird im Körper, also dass der Körper sich in irgendeiner Form auch
daran anpasst an diese niedrige Verfügbarkeit und nicht gleich alle auf dem
Zahnfleisch laufen nach zwei Tagen so,
oh ich hab ja nix gefangen irgendwie, ich kann mich gar nicht mehr bewegen,
weil ich meine Dämmerzustand und so weiter und dann jagen gehen,
passt ja dann irgendwie auch nicht so richtig zusammen. Also, ähm...
Es gibt, wenn ich die Frage ein bisschen anders drehen darf,
es gibt Untersuchungen aus den 60er Jahren noch des letzten Jahrhunderts von Hamill,
ein Amerikaner in Australien, die durchgeführt wurden bei den Aborigines und
zwar jenen zum Beispiel die nahe der Küste leben und solchen die im zentralen Bereich leben.
Wo sie sehr hohe Temperaturschwankungen haben, wo es permanent heiß ist im zentralen Bereich.
Da hat man zum Beispiel herausgefunden, dass deren Körpertemperatur,
wenn die sich schlafen gelegt haben, dass die Körpertemperatur abgefallen ist.
Also die unter die 37 Grad auf 36, 34, 35 in der Nacht. Es ist relativ nachts
auch relativ kühl und der Körper hat nicht dagegen gearbeitet.
Also nicht, dass er jetzt Bewegung und so die 37 hat, sondern er hat das zugelassen.
Während hingegen diejenigen, die an der Küste lebten, die haben dann tatsächlich
ihre Körpertemperatur, wenn ihr ein bisschen abfiegt, haben die entsprechend
durch Muskelzittern und so weiter versucht, diese Körpertemperatur zu halten.
Da war es sozusagen, natürlich ist es ein entsprechender Vorteil,
wenn sie einfach sagen, okay der Körper kriegt jetzt nichts,
der darf nichts für Stoffwechseln, weil sie natürlich dadurch jetzt eine gewisse
Einsparung haben in ihrem Energiestoffwechsel.
Also lässt er das auch zu, dass während der Nacht eben die Temperatur abfällt,
ohne dagegen zu arbeiten. Wir hingegen, wenn wir uns daraus einden,
haben einen sehr schnellen Anstieg unserer.
Stoffwechselaktivität, um die Körpertemperatur zu halten. Noch wesentlich höher
als diejenigen, die da zum Beispiel im tropischen Bereich von Australien gelebt
haben, von den Aborigines.
Also man hat die verglichen gegen Leute aus Nordamerika und Europa im Stoffwechselverbrauch
wie jene, die in der Küste leben oder jene, die dort sind.
Also es gibt kleine Anpassungen an diesem Stoffwechsel und dieser Stoffwechsel
hängt natürlich wiederum mit der Nahrungsaufnahme zusammen.
Wenn ich tatsächlich nicht genügend Nahrung finden kann da im zentralen Bereich,
dann hilft es mir, dass ich eben nachts jetzt nicht 100 oder 200 Kilokalorien dafür verbrenne,
dass ich meine Temperatur die ganze Nacht hochhalte, sondern eigentlich sicher
davon ausgehen kann, dass es am nächsten Tag evolutionär wieder warm wird in
den Bereichen von Australien.
Und die, die da gelebt haben, da ist das so. Da können sie eigentlich davon
ausgehen, dass sie morgen sozusagen wieder mit der aufgehenden Sonne ihre Körpertemperatur
wieder auf ihren Stand bekommen, ohne dass sie dabei was verloren haben.
Also das ist ein sicher evolutionärer Vorteil, nicht alles sofort auf die Karte
zu setzen, um das entsprechend zu aktivieren.
Das heißt es ist schon möglich für den menschlichen Körper auch bei einer niedrigen
Temperatur zumindest im Schlaf für einen bestimmten Zeitraum zu überleben?
Genau, das macht man ja auch teilweise, oder das sind die Überlegungen,
wenn man so entsprechende Kryotherapien,
wo man den Körpertemperatur senkt und hofft dadurch die jeweiligen Organe,
das kommt wieder aufs Organ an, die Organüberlebenszeit zu erhöhen.
Wir sollten ein Herz operieren, dann kommt das Herz ja teilweise aus Holland
und wird hier in der Charité irgendwo eingesetzt.
Dann brauchen sie drei, vier Stunden, ein Herz normalerweise,
wenn es eine normale Temperatur hat, ist das nach ein paar Minuten das Herz
nicht mehr funktionsfähig,
aber wenn Sie das Herz dann bei Temperaturen um ein paar Grad über Null halten,
dann können Sie da mehrere Stunden dieses Herz.
Noch funktionsfähig halten, weil der Stoffwechsel sehr sehr gering ist und dann
bauen sie es hier ein und dann wird es langsam wieder warm und dann kann das
eben der Organismus sozusagen damit den nötigen Nährstoffen versorgen.
Da ist also so eine Herabsetzung von einem Organ in einer bestimmten Temperatur.
Temperatur und Stoffwechsel gehört zusammen. Senken Sie die Temperatur,
senken Sie gleichzeitig den Stoffwechsel. Erhöhen Sie die Temperatur,
steigt der Stoffwechsel.
Also wir müssen mehr Energie zur Verfügung stellen.
Aber warum sind wir dann nicht generell nachts einfach kühler,
weil wir uns weniger Energie verbrauchen?
Ja dann hat man aber wieder die Frage, man ist dann natürlich weniger aktiv,
wenn ich das auf den Gesamtorganismus beziehe.
Aber im Schlaf?
Ja im Schlaf, das ist ja auch etwas was wir, wenn wir tatsächlich sozusagen
uns draußen in der Wildnis irgendwo aufhalten, würde ich sagen es ist sehr schnell
notwendig, dass wenn irgendeine Gefahr droht, dass sie da entsprechen.
Achso wir können uns dann nicht gegen Gefahren wehren und so.
Man ist dann so quasi eingefroren.
Wir wären in einem stumpfen Zustand. Also dann sind sie nicht schnell genug.
Das ist eine Überlebensstrategie sozusagen.
Ja genau, das ist eine Überlebensstrategie. Das kostet alles Energie.
Aber hat natürlich evolutionär einen erheblichen Vorteil, dass wir andere Organismen,
die da nicht so in der Lage sind, eben so ein Krokodil, wenn das unterkühlt
ist, können sie sich das schnappen. Wenn das Ding warm ist, wird's schwierig.
Aber Winterschlaf ist ja auch so ein...
Ja, da hat man zum Beispiel, da ist eine Strategie, da ist eine Strategie,
dass man sieht, okay, ich meine, das ist für mich ein Rätsel,
wie das ein Rätsel, wie die Natur so etwas konstruieren kann.
Also so ein Murmeltier schläft sieben Monate, wacht dann auf und weiß,
wo die Nüsse noch sind oder was er da eingegraben hat. Ich meine, das ist ever.
Und vor allem wie wird so ein Prozess eigentlich hormonell gesteuert,
da fällt die Außentemperatur, dann werden bestimmte Hormone gebildet,
die kennt man heutzutage, also dopaminartige Strukturen.
Und dann wird der Schlaf da eingeleitet und dann ein paar mal zwischendurch werden sie dann wach,
wo man auch noch nicht weiß warum sie eigentlich wach werden, aber dann,
damit ist es auch gut so und dann senken die die Herzfrequenz bis auf ein Zehntel
oder noch mehr und haben dann die Fähigkeit,
wenn es wieder wärmer wird und draußen wieder was zu beißen gibt,
dann marschieren sie wieder und wachen auf und los geht die Reise und dann,
Fünf Monate später geht der ganze Zauber wieder los.
Aber wie wird in der Evolution so etwas eingebaut?
Funktioniert aber auch nur weil die sich dann sozusagen ihre Höhlen bauen wo
sie dann eben nicht gefunden werden.
Ja aber dann auch interessanterweise eben durchaus wenn die Temperatur zu tief
geht also zum Beispiel beim Igel oder wenn das so bei sieben Grad oder so etwas ist ja,
dann wachen die wieder auf deswegen so ein Igel wenn der da schläft und wenn
der nicht aufwacht, Wenn er mehrfach aufwacht, das ist energiereichst,
wenn sie das aufwacht, was dann ein paar Stunden braucht, aber das ist enorm energieverbrauchend.
Wenn das also nur zweimal oder was mehr passiert, dann verhungern die Tiere,
dann schaffen die es nicht mehr bis zum Frühling.
Aber auch das, wenn die da unten natürlich in der Höhle sind,
natürlich sind die Temperaturen nicht so doll, als wenn sie draußen irgendwo
sind, die bauen sich da Höhlengänge, aber trotzdem ist das phänomenal und auch wie die das schaffen.
Denken Sie daran, wenn wir in der Schwerelosigkeit sind und uns nicht bewegen,
dann verlieren wir pro Monat 10% unserer Muskelmasse. Die behalten die Muskelmasse,
die behalten die Knochenmasse. Wie machen die das?
Deswegen hat die europäische Raumfahrtbehörde alleine so eine Gruppe,
die sich nur mit diesen Winterschleifern beschäftigt, um herauszukriegen, wie machen die das?
Welche Hormone sind da am steuern? Wie kriegen die das hin ohne Belastung?
Normalerweise führt das zu einem Abbau. Wenn wir sieben Monate irgendwo liegen
würden, dann wären wir wahrscheinlich eher einer Quale ähnlich.
Oder nicht ganz so, aber jedenfalls wird entsprechend Muskelmasse verloren und Knaumasse.
Bevor wir nochmal auf diese ganzen Weltraum Aspekte kommen, immer noch einen
Bereich interessieren, der auch noch hier so eine Rolle spielt und das ist so die Zeit.
Wir sind ja irgendwie ganz gut getaktete Wesen in gewisser Hinsicht,
klar wir leben mit der Sonne auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise und naja
es gibt ja auch so Begriffe so die innere Umgebung.
Leute sind eher Eulen und Lerchen,
ich bin definitiv eher eine Eule,
so kann ich an mir festmachen, nicht dass ich nicht auch mal davon profitiere
früh aufzustehen, finde ich
mal ganz interessant, aber die Tendenz geht dann doch eher in den Abend.
Was macht es aus und was genau repariert eigentlich der Mensch im Schlaf?
Also was wird denn da jetzt getan? Ich meine gut, die Temperatur wird hochgehalten,
damit man schnell wieder aufwachen kann.
Aber warum schlafen wir denn überhaupt ein? Ja.
Gute Frage, Physiologen sind sich nicht klar warum man eigentlich den Schlaf braucht,
man weiß nur wir brauchen ihn für eine gewisse Zeit das ist richtig der eine
vielleicht auch ein bisschen kürzer und der eine ein bisschen länger als der
andere aber ganz genau geklärt warum wir das physiologisch brauchen ist nicht klar.
Es gibt sogar einige Leute die können gar nicht schlafen so einige Fälle sind
bekannt die schlafen gar nicht.
Wie es gibt Menschen die gar nicht schlafen, gibt es so einzelne Fälle.
Ohne dass man den Eindruck hat, dass die was leiden?
Ohne das zu sehen, nein.
Aber das heißt ja dann im Umkehrschluss wahrscheinlich auch es gibt Leute die
brauchen generell weniger Schlaf und es gibt welche die brauchen generell mehr Schlaf?
Ja es gibt da Unterschiede, die eine braucht eben sechs Stunden oder vier Stunden,
der andere kommt mit seinen acht
Stunden mal gerade so hin, gibt es aber warum und wieso das jetzt ist.
Wichtig ist, dass wir sozusagen natürlich so eine gewisse Struktur in der Temperatur haben,
weil, Und das ist hauptsächlich die Temperatur,
die das da reagiert oder so einen internen Rhythmus, weil wir natürlich die
Steuerung brauchen, wann bestimmte Hormone besonders deutlich ausgeschieden
werden müssen und wann ist das dann eher nicht so.
Zwischen aktiver Phase und Ruhephase, zum Beispiel morgens gegen 5 Uhr zum Beispiel
haben wir die tiefsten Temperaturen, tief heißt hier 36 Grad oder so.
Die tiefste Körpertemperatur und dann steigt aber gleichzeitig,
das ist dann auch ein Signal für zum Beispiel das Cortisol,
das steigt dann an bis in den Dach hinein und das führt dann dazu,
dass wir unter anderem wach werden und uns aktiv halten.
Für körperliche Aktivitäten zum Beispiel haben wir eine hohe Körpertemperatur,
die höchste Temperatur haben wir meistens so zwischen 17 und 19 Uhr abends, wir hier.
Das ist deswegen auch wichtig zum Beispiel, wenn Sie irgendwelche sportlichen
Wegkämpfe haben, also so einen 100 Meter Lauf oder so, oder 400 Meter Lauf,
den würden Sie nicht morgens machen.
Da kriegen Sie keine Weltklasse Zeiten, den machen Sie immer zwischen irgendwann,
schauen Sie mal, 16, 18 Uhr, 19 Uhr, da sind diese kurzen Strecken.
Wenn sie einen Marathon laufen, den wollen sie nicht laufen,
wenn sie die höchste Temperatur im Körper haben, sondern das findet in der Regel
morgens statt, um 9 Uhr oder um 8 Uhr.
Also die sind ganz in die, morgens, wenn wir da eine relativ noch geringe Temperatur
haben, die dann über den Tag hinweg an der, die anderen brauchen eine hohe Temperatur,
Betriebstemperatur, wenn sie eben halt kurzfristig sehr sehr hohe Geschwindigkeiten
brauchen, wo der Muskel dann da arbeiten kann.
Also der Taktgeber dafür ist zum Beispiel jetzt wiederum die Temperatur oder der Stoffwechsel.
Der wird gesteuert durch eine Struktur im Gehirn, die dann entsprechend vorgibt,
wie dieser Rhythmus zu sein hat.
Wie so eine Sinuskurve ist diese Körpertemperatur, morgens tiefsten und ruhigsten
am Abend und wenn sie das durcheinander bringen,
zum Beispiel die armen Leute die jetzt Schichtbetrieb haben und dann in wechselnden
Schichten arbeiten müssen,
einmal morgens, dann nächste Woche vielleicht nachmittags, oder dann noch schlimmer
übernächste Woche dann in der Nachtschicht, dass die sind maximal belastet,
das ist auch wieder eine extreme Umwelt.
Veränderungen in dem Schichtrhythmus sind für den Körper sehr belastend und das führt dann dazu,
dass sie unter Umständen zum Beispiel dann eher Stoffwechselveränderungen haben,
dass sie unter Umständen auch Erkrankungen wie Diabetes fördern oder dann auch
eine Hypertonie beziehungsweise eine entsprechende zu viel Essen,
wenn sie sich dabei nicht bewegen.
Also wir haben solche Untersuchungen insbesondere bei chilenischen Bergarbeitern
gemacht, die diese starken Rhythmusschwankungen haben in der Höhe.
Die arbeiten zwölf Stunden in der Höhe, in 4.000 Metern Höhe und dann schlafen
die auf 3.000 Metern Höhe und dann fahren sie wieder hoch und wieder runter
und dann fahren sie ganz runter ans Meer, dann sind sie auf null.
Also die sind solchen Belastungen ausgesetzt und da sind eben bestimmte Erkrankungen,
die man im weiteren zusammenfasst als das sogenannte metabolische Syndrom,
wie das im akademischen Bereich heißt, die sind da häufiger bei denen anzutreffen
als bei den Normalbürgern.
Unser Stadtleben hier läuft nur dadurch, dass wir irgendwelche Schichtarbeiten
machen. Wie sie schon richtig sagen, aha, so ist das heute morgen hier,
wer ist denn jetzt schon unterwegs, der Mölle ist schon weg,
der muss da um 5 Uhr aus Frohnau gekommen sein oder woher.
Dafür brauchen wir, also das ist sinnvoll,
einen gewissen Takt geben, ich würde mal sagen wie beim Orchester,
der den Takt vorgibt, okay jetzt ist das dran, jetzt ist das dran,
jetzt ist das dran und das macht die Temperatur, das ist sozusagen der Konzertmeister vorne.
Jetzt ist die Temperatur am tiefsten, bald musst du jetzt aufwachen und dann
bald musst du ran an die Arbeit und dann wenn die Temperatur dann wieder an ist,
dann geht das wieder raus und das ist der Konzertmeister, ist diese Temperatur,
wieder sind wir beim Stoffwechsel, das ist ganz entscheidend.
Aber innere Uhr gibt's.
Die in der Uhr gibt es und die wird irgendwo im Hypothalamus von bestimmten
Zellen produziert und die orientieren sich dann zum Beispiel natürlich auch
nach dem Sonnenlicht das geht da ein,
also wenn sie da nur in der Dunkelheit leben oder nur in Höhlen leben dann merkt
man zum Beispiel geht auch dieser innere Rhythmus geht dann verloren dann sind
sie nicht mehr 24 Stunden, ist der Rhythmus, sondern es war 36 Stunden oder 50 Stunden.
Und Leute, die mehrere Wochen in so Höhlen waren, die sind teilweise 70 Stunden wach gewesen.
Also dann geht das auch verloren, dieses Zeitum.
Und es gibt eine Reihe von Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Parkinson,
da verlieren sie dieses Zeitgefühl.
Dann haben sie nicht mehr die Struktur, wie lang war das jetzt oder wie viel
Zeit brauchte ich dafür.
Ja das ist interessant das ist ein interessantes zeitgefühl wie lange ist jetzt
eine minute oder wie lange ist jetzt eine stunde oder wie lange haben wir jetzt gerade hier geredet.
Podcast entzieht sich auch jeglicher zeiteinteilung das stimmt und sind sie
ein führer gegen die sommerzeit.
Ich halte das für aufoktroyiert, wenn man da auch einmal da umswitcht,
ich bin dagegen, man sollte das nicht verändern.
Es hat auch wenig gebracht an sich an dem, was ich jedenfalls gelesen habe,
dass dadurch tatsächlich jetzt irgendein Stromverbrauch sich wesentlich rechen
beispielsweise, aber das ist ein anderes Feld, da lassen wir mal die Experten
eher drauf gucken, was das bringt.
Ja, ich glaube, da sind auch viele Erläuterungen erst im Nachgang gemacht worden.
Das Ganze ist ja irgendwie im Rahmen der Kriege eingeführt worden,
also eher so Versorgungsgründe gehabt.
Die Frage war ja eher, lässt sich das irgendwie medizinisch beobachten,
dass es negative Auswirkungen hat auf Menschen?
Also wenn man die normalerweise, wenn man diese unterschiedlichen Zeitrhythmen
nimmt, dann ist das eine zusätzliche Belastung für den Menschen.
Also der braucht solche Rhythmik, der hat ja auch seine,
auch evolutionär wieder seinen Ursprung vermutlich in den Organismen oder es
ist eine sehr alte Struktur, wenn man genetisch in diese genetischen guckt,
die für diese Zellen, diese neuronalen Netzwerke zuständig ist,
da sieht man das sind ganz einfache strukturen haben das auch schon da ist es
halt dass man sich vorstellt das besonders wichtig war für die beurteilung,
eben küsten nahen bereich wann zum beispiel haben wir jetzt tag wann haben wir
entsprechende überflutung der bereiche da ist es sozusagen so eine rhythmus
kennung wann ich was machen muss,
ist von erheblicher Bedeutung, genauso gut wie ich als schwebendes Plankton
oder so was wissen muss, wann ist es jetzt oben, wann ist es dunkel, wann ist es hell,
wann verändere ich sozusagen meine Lage innerhalb eines Teiches oder einer See,
dann weiß ich okay, jetzt muss ich hoch gehen, damit ich oben das und das vorfinde
und wenn das weg ist, dann gehe ich lieber wieder runter.
Das bringt ja auch einige Organismen, hier zum Beispiel in Brandenburg hatte
ich da eine interessante Studie gesehen,
wo man die Seen untersucht hat, die kommen durch die artifizielle Beleuchtung
kommen jetzt die Organismen,
insbesondere die dort, die Mikroorganismen, die sich nach diesem Lichtschema
ernähren, die kommen da durcheinander, weil jetzt permanent da,
Großberlin, die Sonne scheint auf Gothors.
Das ist, da sieht man wie wir sozusagen die gesamte Umwelt bis hin zu den Zeitstrukturen
im Prinzip verändern und das ist dann für diese Organismen so eine extreme Belastung.
Also wir müssen diese Extremgeister nicht so weit suchen, die sind hier in kleinster Umgebung.
Ja wir schaffen uns das ja auch selbst, gibt ja den schönen Begriff des Jetlag,
der auch erst mit der Erfindung des Jets dann sozusagen wirklich eine Rolle gespielt hat,
das ist in dem Moment wo man also große Strecken überbrückt und der Tag dann
auf einmal extrem viel länger und extrem viel kürzer wird, das hat vielleicht
jeder der so eine Reise schon mal gemacht hat.
Ostflüge verträgt man wesentlich schlechter als wenn man in der Westen,
also Tag zu verlängern. Ist nicht so schlimm, aber warum?
Ja das ist, der Organismus hat, einen Tag zu verlängern an Aktivität ist etwas
was so naturgemäß vorkommt,
also Peter Fox würde es hier wahrscheinlich in Berlin sagen,
das ist geradezu die Regel, dass die Tage verlängert werden.
Ja.
Einen Tag zu verkürzen, das ist etwas evolutionär, was so nicht vorgesehen war.
Insofern ist diese Verkürzung schon nachvollziehbar, dass uns das mehr stört
als die Verlängerung eines Tages.
Dann kommen wir doch vielleicht doch nochmal so ein bisschen auf die Raumfahrt. Also sie haben ja auch,
hab's schon angedeutet, einige Projekte begleitet und da spielt natürlich vor
allem aber eben nicht nur Schwerkraft eine Rolle,
aber eben auch so diese, wo wir schon ansatzweise darüber gesprochen haben,
so die Isolationsfragen.
Ich hatte hier auch zu dem Projekt Mars 500 auch schon mal eine Sendung gemacht.
Das ist auch schon ein bisschen her. Muss ich gerade mal nachschlagen.
Wie lange habe ich denn das...
Das ist... ach Gott, das ist auch schon etwas...
2011 genau eine langzeitsstudie die halt die psychischen belastungen einer möglichen
mars mission beobachtet hat wo ja menschen ich weiß gar nicht wie viel waren
es, 7,8 Leute oder sowas da.
Da waren 6. Größen von 6 Leuten über eben so die dauer eines theoretischen mars
flugs was man eben so meint wie lange das so dauert oder was man einfach weiß wie lange das dauert.
500 Tage sind eigentlich nur die Hälfte.
Nur die Hälfte genau, es war nur einmal hidden sozusagen. Und mehr wollte man
den Leuten dann nicht zumuten, ich glaube das war 2010, 2011 war diese Studie
gewesen. Das war ein bisschen mehr als ein Jahr.
Ja knapp anderthalb Jahre. Inwiefern haben Sie daran teilgenommen?
Da haben wir zum Beispiel den zirkadianen Rhythmus untersucht,
also die Veränderungen der Körpertemperatur bei dieser Isolation,
weil wir sehen wollten, wenn die da abgekapselt sind, ohne dass sie Sonnenlicht bekommen,
sondern nur sozusagen über die Uhr gesteuert, wann Tag ist, wann Nacht ist,
durch das was sie machen, inwieweit reicht das aus, um den zirkadianen Rhythmus zu behalten?
Ja haben wir gesehen das reicht an sich nach den untersuchungen die wir dann
gemacht haben aber man hat gesehen okay der eine oder andere hatten sehr starken
inneren rhythmus gehabt es gab welche die haben deren rhythmus hat sich deutlich.
Abgeschwächt, also da waren die Schwankungen in der Temperatur geringer und interessanterweise,
als im sozusagen letzten Drittel, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
hat man den sechs Probanden freigelassen, wann sie denn essen.
Ja, sonst war es immer geregelt, Frühstück, Mittagessen, Abendessen. Ja, Liebling.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, okay, jetzt lösen wir das auf, ihr könnt,
Jeder soll bitte selbst entscheiden wann er Nahrung zu sich nimmt.
In dem Augenblick gingen die einzelnen Kurven total durcheinander.
Da haben wir alle einen eigenen Wert gefunden, da hat man gesehen okay diese
Essensvorgabe im Zeithorizont auch wiederum stoffwechselmäßig ist ganz entscheidend
für den zirkadianen Rhythmus.
Diese Taktung von außen, wie Mönche, die jeden Morgen sagen,
um 5 Uhr ist Gottesdienst und dann um 18 Uhr ist das und das und so weiter.
Diese feste Zeitstruktur hat dazu geführt, dass sie einen entsprechenden Rhythmus behalten haben.
Und wenn sie den wegnehmen und die Stoffwechsel sozusagen jedem einzelnen überlassen,
haben sie da Unterschiede.
Das ist natürlich sehr kritisch, sie wollen natürlich nicht Leute haben,
die jetzt alle in ihrem Rhythmus da irgendwie unterschiedlich sind,
weil sie müssen so eine Mission durchführen, die müssen alle ihren klaren Rhythmus haben.
Der muss auch untereinander abgestimmt sein, sonst ist derjenige,
der vielleicht für die Maschinen oder für die Elektronik oder für was auch immer
zuständig ist, ist dann nicht so optimal ansprechbar.
Je nachdem, wo wir uns in der Zeitachse befinden, ist unsere Leistungsfähigkeit unterschiedlich.
Morgens sind wir für kognitive Sachen in der Regel besser gerechnet zwischen 9 und 11 Uhr.
Danach normalerweise nimmt uns das schon wieder die Leistungsfähigkeit ab.
Für manche ist das aber erst der Bereich, wo sie aufstehen.
Wenn sie Leute haben, die alle durcheinander sind, dann hat man da vielleicht
Schwierigkeiten in der Kommunikation.
Also wir haben jetzt um 13 Uhr angefangen, normalerweise würde ich sagen ist
so 11 Uhr bei mir so der sweet spot so.
Ja gut dann ist es halt ein bisschen verschoben, ich habe heute morgen um 7
Uhr angefangen von daher bin ich ein bisschen länger schon.
Jetzt gehen die beiden Wege wahrscheinlich auch auseinander und heute Abend
um 22 Uhr neist sich bei mir wahrscheinlich ein Bedürfnis zur Ruhe zu kommen,
Während vielleicht bei Ihnen noch das eine oder andere ansteht,
was noch zu erledigen ist.
Ja, dann werde ich mal richtig kreativ sein und muss forschen.
Ja, also das war ein Teil der Untersuchung, die wir da gemacht haben.
Und dann, wie wir nochmal betonen, das ist nur die Hälfte einer Mars Mission.
Also nach den heutigen Vorstellungen brauchen sie ungefähr 1000 Tage für die gesamte Mission.
Und das heißt, sie müssen auch, ich glaube bei einer 400 Tage oder was müsste
man einrechnen, die man dann auf dem Mond bleibt, um dann da wieder die richtige
Schleife zurückzufinden. Da gibt es unterschiedliche Strategien, wie man das macht.
Jetzt weiß ich auch wie lange es war. Es war halt 500 Tage.
Manche Sachen sind dann doch ein bisschen zu offensichtlich.
Aber auch bei der MIR und bei der ISS waren sie an Projekten beteiligt,
da ging es dann mehr um Schwerelosigkeit oder Strahlung?
Ne, da ging es hauptsächlich um Anpassung des Herz-Kreislauf-Systems und hier
insbesondere des Blutes, des Zusammensetzens des Blutes und ob die Blutbildung
anders ist in der Schwerelosigkeit.
Und ist sie?
Warum das jetzt so ist, ist im Einzelnen auch noch nicht erklärt,
aber wir konnten ganz klar sehen,
dass ein Hormon, das für die Bildung von roten Blutzellen, die dafür zuständig
sind, dass eben Sauerstoff transportiert wird, das nimmt schon am ersten Tag
oben in der Schwerlosigkeit eben dieses Hormon ab.
Und wenn es dann drei oder vier Tage oder nächste Woche, dann haben wir es kaum
mehr nachweisen können. Das heißt, das existiert.
Und es ist sogar so, dass Blutzellen, die vorhanden sind, die werden tatsächlich
weggefangen und es kommt zu einer Abnahme dieser roten Blutzellen.
Das klingt zunächst einmal besorgniserregend, weil wenn das so weiterging,
dann hätten wir keine Transportierenden mehr. Aber das pendelt sich dann ein,
nach mehreren 2-3 Wochen, dann pendelt sich das so ein und bleibt dann auf einem
geringeren Hormonspiegel besteht.
Und die Flüge, die jetzt ja auch auf der ISS stattgefunden haben,
bestätigen, dass es da ein neues Niveau gibt.
Offensichtlich hängt es zusammen mit der Flüssigkeitsverschiebung in der Spirulosigkeit.
Wenn ich hier jetzt stehen würde, wären 70 Prozent meines Blutvolumens unterhalb des Herzens,
in der Schwerelosigkeit hätte ich hier ein sehr hohes Blutvolumen im oberen
Körperbereich und das misst der Körper oder verrechnet er so vermutlich,
okay ich habe zu viel Flüssigkeit in meinem Körperkern, wird das los,
dann scheidet er vielleicht Flüssigkeit aus, aber er baut auch Zellen ab,
die in dem Blut eben heute herumschwärmen, wie die roten Blutzellen.
Und das führt dann dazu, dass diese gesenkt ist, diese Anzahl der roten Blutzellen.
Aber das passt sich dem neuen Situation halt an. Da brauchen wir offensichtlich
nicht mehr. Wir brauchen die allerdings, wenn wir dann wieder hier auf der Erde landen.
Da denkt der Körper nicht, da denkt der wieder rein physiologisch,
der macht sich jetzt keine Sorgen darüber, dass ich irgendwann wieder auf diesem
Planeten lande, sondern der sieht nur halt, ich brauche das nicht,
hier oben habe ich das nicht nötig, also weg damit.
Aber es ist zumindest keine unmittelbare Auswirkung
der Schwerkraft das
jetzt sozusagen an den Körper überall gezogen wird das ist eigentlich nicht
das Ding sondern da kommt wieder der Körper als Sensornetzwerk mit rein der
einfach feststellt weil die Schwerkraft anders ist verteilen sich Dinge anders
irgendwo ist mehr als es sein soll und weniger als sonst.
Und dann passt sich das auf ein neues Niveau an, auch wieder diese Dynamik des Systems,
die Dynamik unseres Körpers, das ist geradezu grandios, wie der sich dieser
völlig neuen Situation auf seine Weise eben spezifisch anpasst und da ein neues Niveau findet.
Und wenn er dann natürlich wieder ruckartig in das Gravitationsfeld der Erde
kommt, wie das dann einige Astronauten sind, die dann eben aussteigen und denen
dann auch ein bisschen schwindelig wird, weil sie unten auf der Erde landen,
da brauchen sie nämlich diese ganzen Zellen wieder und zwar mehr davon.
Deswegen haben die dann Schwierigkeiten, dann dauert es wieder ein paar Wochen
in der Regel das ist interessant, guter Punkt.
Es dauert in der Regel fast für alle Organe, Organsysteme die von der schwere
Kraft oder schwerer Losigkeit beeinflusst werden,
dauert es, beinahe identisch lange bis sie hier wieder auf der Erde den Zustand
haben, also wenn sie, Gleichgewichtsorgan ist schon den ersten 6-7 Tagen oben
wie gesagt ein bisschen durcheinander, weil das haben wir hier nicht auf der Erde.
Es braucht hier 6-7 Tage, wenn die zurückkommen, dann ist das auch wieder geregelt.
Abbau von Muskelmasse geht da oben wie gesagt 10% pro Monat vielleicht sogar
noch mehr teilweise, bestimmte Muskulaturen.
Dauert auch einen Monat, wenn sie es hier wieder aufbauen oder zwei Monate,
kommt ganz drauf an wie lange sie oben waren.
Also der Zeitraum, den sie in der Schwerelosigkeit sind, zurückgekommen,
dauert es ungefähr genau die selbe Zeit, das wieder aufzubauen.
Also das sind so dynamische Vorgänge, die wir halt in der Raumfahrtmedizin,
und das sind interessante Beobachtungen, weil die natürlich auch tatsächlich klinisch wichtig sind.
Stellen Sie sich vor, jemand hat irgendwie mehrere Knochen gebrochen und liegt
dann mehrere Wochen im Bett.
Dann sind diese Erkenntnisse aus der Raumfahrt, wo man die Leute in eine absolute
Schwerelosigkeit bringt, sind hilfreich bei der Entwicklung von Gegenmaßnahmen.
Und kann man jetzt davon ausgehen, dass Menschen jetzt so Star Trek mäßig lang,
also über längere Zeit, sagen wir mal so jahrelang im All irgendwie überleben?
Also im All als in sagen wir mal jetzt so Low Earth Orbit so wie die ISS so.
Also abgesehen davon, dass das wahrscheinlich dann auch irgendwann nervt,
wenn man auch mal andere Sachen sehen möchte, weil es ist ja auch immer so ein
höllischer Lärm in so einer Maschine die ganze Zeit. zu sein.
Aber so rein physiologisch geht dann irgendwann...
Verbraucht sich das dann irgendwann und dann macht der körper nicht mehr mit
oder pendelt er sich eigentlich tendenziell.
Pendelt sich eher ein wobei die Strahlung natürlich etwas ist oder Strahlungseinflüsse.
Die können dem ganzen System relativ schnell ein Ende setzen also wenn wir wirklich
sehr sehr hohe kosmische Strahlung kam aufgrund von Protoparenzen,
Ausbrüchen auf der Sonne oder nahegelegene Supernova in unserem System,
von der wir im Augenblick nicht ahnen, dass da was aus uns zukommt,
dann sind, das ist unter Umständen eine wirklich lebensgefährliche Situation.
Die Sehnerv kommt sozusagen aus dem Gehirn durch den Nervenkanal hindurch und
wenn da jetzt höher Druck ist,
dann haben die Astronauten dann und wann eben deutliche Einschränkungen ihres
Visus, also ihrer Sehkraft.
Und bei einigen ist das offensichtlich so, dass sich das auch nicht wieder zurückbildet, wenn sie wunden sind.
Außerdem ist es so, dass eben Gehirnstrukturen offensichtlich unter Druck stehen,
da ist man gerade bei, das ist ein eigenes, neues Forschungsfeld,
das ist auch so eine Sache,
es wäre eigentlich am besten, wir würden irgendwie,
wie das bei Odyssee 2013,
am besten, wir lassen das Ding rotieren, machen uns ein eigenes Schwerkraftfeld,
Dann haben wir diese ganzen Probleme mit dem Ab- und Hinaufbau,
Abbau, Trainingsgeräte, jeden Tag müssen die Astronauten da oben auf der Eise
zwei Stunden trainieren, jeden Tag.
Teuerste Fitnessstudio auf der Welt, um nicht abzubauen,
um die Muskelmasse nicht abzubauen und Herzkreislaufe abzubauen,
wenn wir das ganze Ding und das ist eigentlich nur eine Frage von Energie,
wenn wir Energie haben könnte man das Ding rotieren, vielleicht braucht man auch gar nicht 1G,
also eine Schwerkraft wie auf der Erde, vielleicht brauchen wir auch nur 0,5G,
also die Hälfte an Schwerkraft, um manche Prozesse entweder so zu verlangsamen
oder vielleicht auch ganz zu verhindern, dann könnte man sich viel dieser Trainingsgeschichten
da sparen, wenn wir das Ding einfach rotieren und machen da oben Schwerkraft.
Ich glaube es ist nicht nur eine Frage der Energie, es ist auch so ein mechanisches Problem.
In der Struktur. Ja wenn man permanent so rotierende Körper hat und so weiter,
dann ist natürlich viel Abnutzung, das hält dann alles nicht so lange.
Schon auf der Erde müssen ja rotierende Sachen extrem gewartet werden,
das ist dann im einen natürlich immer so eine Sache.
Also wurde schon mal drüber nachgedacht, so ist es nicht, aber am Ende stellt
man wahrscheinlich sowieso immer fest,
dass der Nico, wenn er ein Recht hatte, 2001 kam er ja irgendwie die letzten
50 Jahre Technologieentwicklung schön nachblättern, das war alles schon auf dem großen Bildschirm.
Ja.
Gerade mal nachgeschlagen, längster Aufenthalt im All, 437 Tage bisher.
Poljakow. Genau, Poljakow und...
Den habe ich gesehen, einen Tag später als er runter kam. Da war ich damals gerade in Star City.
Da war er direkt aus da irgendwo, der kam ja in Kasachstan, wo er gelandet ist.
Da wurde er dann nach Star City gebracht in Moskau. Wir hatten auch einen Versuch.
Und der konnte an dem Tag schon wieder laufen. Also 24, 48 Stunden später war
der da auf dem Kanken gesehen, gesehen, wie er da runterkommt,
konnte der schon wieder ohne, dass er sich da irgendwo festhalten muss oder sowas.
Ich meine, meine Güte, der ist wirklich anderthalb Jahre da oben im Hall,
schwerelos und kann am nächsten Tag wieder laufen.
Das nenne ich Flexibilität.
Aber der hätte auch seine zwei Stunden dann abgerissen jeden Tag.
Ja, das muss er, wenn er es nicht macht,
also das hat man gemerkt, wenn die nicht trainieren, dann haben die da nach
zwei Wochen schon deutliche Probleme,
das war in den ersten Raumflügen, die dann so zwei Wochen waren ohne Trainingslater,
da haben die wirklich schon gerade im Herzmuskelkreislauf erhebliche Probleme
gehabt, da kommen sie nicht drum rum.
Das heißt würde man jetzt keinen Sport treiben, dann wäre es bald vorbei?
Also da oben solange sie da in dem Environment bleiben ist das okay aber sobald
sie dann wieder runterkommen und auf 1G sind,
dann haben sie Probleme weil dieser Wechsel ist dann innerhalb von,
wenn sie aus der Erdumlaufbahn, Low Earth Orbit runtergehen,
das ist 45 Minuten später landen sie da irgendwo in Kasachstan oder in der Mojave,
wenn sie da früher mit dem Shuttle geflogen sind.
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Da muss der Körper sich innerhalb von einer Stunde wieder auf die Schwerkraft
einplanen, die vorher nicht da war.
Dazu sind sie nicht in der Lage, wenn sie nicht trainiert haben.
Das sind immer so Realitäten, die einem immer so diese schönen Star Wars Träume
so schnell zerplatzen lassen.
Wo man immer so hier jetzt fliegen wir mal auf dem Planeten,
laufen wir mal da rum und so weiter. Und irgendwie das Gefühl so okay,
das ganze Universum alles eingehen, so wird's ja dann wahrscheinlich nicht laufen.
Das heißt mal so eben auf einem anderen Planeten landen und da einfach so vor
sich hin leben ohne weiteres ist nicht so einfach.
Ja vor allen Dingen, wo wollen wir den Planeten, wie wollen wir da hinkommen,
also ich meine da müssen wir schon mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit uns hier hin bewegen,
ich meine nächste Alpha Centauri ist glaube ich so 4,8 oder irgendwas,
also 50 Billionen Kilometer entfernt.
Ist ja in einer anderen Galaxie, da herrschen ja ganz andere planetare Dichten.
Also ich hab jetzt nur gerade unsere Nähe im Kreis betrachtet.
Das ist schon sehr klug, das ist mir auch später erst aufgefallen,
dass sie einfach dieses in a galaxy far far away,
so das, damit haben sie sich natürlich bei Dumbledore offen gelassen,
ihr Milchstraßler, ihr habt ja nix gewohnt irgendwie, habt euch halt scheiße entwickelt.
Ja wir haben ein beschränktes Bild. Auf jeden Fall. Das wissen wir schon vom
Universum. Keine Ahnung haben wir.
Vielleicht so zum Abschluss, also Parabelflügel haben sie sich aber auch angeschaut,
also ich hab's ja schon erwähnt,
ich hatte ja mal die Gelegenheit da mitzufliegen und fand es wirklich grandios,
hätte mich im Nachhinein gerne noch mehr drauf vorbereitet, aber es trifft einen
dann glaub ich dann doch irgendwie unvorbereitet, was kann man denn da medizinisch
mitnehmen aus solchen kurzen Phasen?
Ja zum Beispiel, meine eigene Experimente gingen tatsächlich über diesen Fluidshift,
also diese Flüssigkeitsverlagerung.
Wie schnell ist das eigentlich im Körper, ist das jetzt, brauche ich dafür Tage
oder geht das innerhalb von einer Stunde oder ist das akut, wenn ich jetzt in
die Schwerelosigkeit komme.
Das haben wir mit bestimmten Sensoren, haben wir zum Beispiel gemessen,
wie sich die Schichtdicke der Haut verändert, wenn wir in die Schwerelosigkeit kommen.
Und ich war davon ausgegangen, okay das ist etwas, was physikalisch einfach
im Sekundenbereich passiert.
Flüssigkeit wird unverlagert so, als wenn ich mich, wenn man so will, auf den Kopf stelle.
Und in der Tat ist das so. Die Flüssigkeit in dem Gefäßsystem,
innerhalb von 2-3 Sekunden, und so ein Parabel in der Schwerlosigkeit,
die dauert 20 Sekunden, kommt auf den Flugbahnen an, oder eben halt 30 Sekunden.
Da konnten wir das messen, dass das ein Vorgang ist, der dazu führt,
dass vermehrt Blutvolumen dann im Gehirn ist und in der Haut und das kann man
zum Beispiel da untersuchen.
Andere Untersuchungen gehen zum Beispiel dahin, die gucken sich an,
welche kognitiven Veränderungen hat man,
wenn man bestimmte Bilder oder bestimmte Tests macht, wo man die Schwerkraft
braucht normalerweise als Koordinator für einen, Wenn ihr einfach wegfällt als
einen Informationspunkt, wie verändert sich dann?
Koordinationsfähigkeit in einem Spiel zum Beispiel bestimmte Löcher zu finden
oder bestimmte Kugeln irgendwo reinzubringen.
Also was macht unser Gehirn? Das sind Untersuchungen.
Dann gibt es Untersuchungen, die sich damit beschäftigen, wie verändert sich
durch diese Flüssigkeitsverlagerung jetzt die thermische Situation am Kopf.
Weil in der Schwerelosigkeit haben sie auch keine, wie wir das nennen,
natürliche Konvektion.
Wenn ich jetzt hier sitze oder wenn ich hier noch anders, wenn ich hier auf
der Erde hier nackt stehen würde, da wäre 600 Liter Luft an mir vorbeiströmen.
Kalte Luft ist unten, warme Luft ist oben.
Also warme Luft ist leichter und deswegen strömt die sozusagen meinem Körper
vorbei. In der Schwerelosigkeit ist das nicht, in der Schwerelosigkeit haben
wir das. Das ist egal, ob es kalt oder warm ist, deswegen haben wir da keine
natürliche Konvektion.
Sieht man ja an Kerzenflammen. Richtig, genau.
Sie sind einfach nur so eine Kugel. Also wie so eine Zwiebel,
fällt dann die Temperatur zu Seite hin ab und ist eben keine Flamme,
Flammenstruktur, wo ich dann sehe, ok, oben am Kopf ist es warm.
Und nur dort, hier sieht man halt, der ganze Körper ist wie so eine Zwiebelschalenartige
Temperaturverteilung an seiner Oberfläche nach außen hin.
Zumal sie dann noch das Problem haben, wenn sie oben in der Schwerelosigkeit
schwitzen, das ist eine Sache, die würde ich noch mal gerne beim Paradoflucher
untersetzen, was passiert eigentlich, wenn sie in der Schwerelosigkeit schwitzen,
geht dann der Schweiß, wie kommt der von der Hautoberfläche ab?
Ich habe eher den Verdacht, dass die Adhäsionskräfte, also die Kräfte,
die dazu führen die Flüssigkeit zusammenzuhalten, größer sind,
als die durch die Verdampfung entstehende Energiemenge und sodass sich dann
der Schweiß in so großen Latschen auf der Haut sammelt.
Aber das haben wir bisher noch nicht durchgekriegt, das Forschungsprojekt.
Würde ich gerne noch mal machen.
Aber es gibt jetzt keine Berichte, dass da alle total verschwitzt sind die ganze
Zeit oder die ganze Zeit feucht.
Ja wenn sie so einzelne Sportler, also wenn sie die fragen, dann sagen die ok
manchmal habe ich so mehrere...
Ich meine jetzt oben auf der ISS?
Ja wenn sie da oben Sport treiben, dann haben sie hinten auf einmal so ein Bubble
da hinten auf der Rückseite.
Achso wenn man dort Sport tritt.
Ja wenn man dort Sport tritt. Wenn sie da auf dem Laufband sind und die laufen ihre...
Einige der Astronauten haben da oben schon Marathonläufe durchgeführt.
Unten startete der Boston Marathon
und oben war die Läuferin auch auf der Raumstation. Ist da mitgelaufen.
Hatte aber in der Zwischenzeit dann glaube ich dreimal die Erde umrundet oder was scheißt.
Das ist der Effizienz auf jeden Fall.
Viermal.
Jetzt ändert sich ja die Raumfahrt gerade ein bisschen durch verschiedenste Faktoren.
Der Mond spielt auf einmal wieder eine Rolle. Über den Mars wird ja nun schon längere Zeit geredet.
Also alles scheint so ein bisschen in den Startlöchern zu sein.
Dafür wieder längere Missionen mit Menschen zu machen. Ich hatte ja vor kurzem
auch über die Artemis Mission gesprochen, die jetzt ja im Prinzip den nächsten
Schritt zu gehen scheint.
Artemis 2 wird dann schon wieder mit Astronauten sein und dann Artemis 3 vielleicht
dann eben auch wieder mit Astronauten auf der Mondoberfläche.
Was sind denn das sozusagen für neue Voraussetzungen oder neue Anforderungen
an die Physiologie für diese Missionen die jetzt kommen?
Ja, gute Frage. Wir sind im Augenblick als Team gerade mit einem Sensor,
habe ich gerade gestern gehört, dass unsere Chancen steigen,
dass wir auf der Artemis 4 Mission, das ist glaube ich das,
das den Mond umkreisen soll, dass unser Gerät dort mitfliegt von der ESA,
finanziert vom DLR, dem Deutschen Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt.
Da messen wir zum Beispiel die Körpertemperatur jetzt bei verschiedenen Aktivitäten
der Astronauten in der Kapsel.
Also wenn die ihre Ruhephasen wieder haben, wie die Körpertemperatur sich verhält.
Darüber gibt es für diese Aufenthalte außerhalb der Erdumlaufbahn noch sehr wenige Daten.
Nur damals von den Apollo-Missionen gibt es da einzelne Kurven und die wollen
wir mit einem bestimmten Gerät erfassen. Ich hoffe wir bleiben dabei.
Da sind natürlich viele Forscher interessiert selber da irgendwie auf die Mission zu kommen.
Aber im Augenblick laufen jetzt die Vorbereitungen und ich bin nächste Woche
in Houston, wo wir zum Beispiel die entsprechenden Vorbereitungen treffen für
eine Vorstudie, die jetzt auf der ISS stattfindet.
Das heißt sogenannte T-mini heißt das Gerät. Temperatur, Messgerät, miniaturisiert.
Das misst sozusagen die Temperatur am Kopf und das wird getragen wie so ein
Stirnband und kann dann mehrere Tage die Temperatur am Kopf in dem Stirnband
aufzeichnen und daraus können wir dann wiederum diesen circadian Rhythmus entsprechend
ermitteln und können dann auch sehen,
wie hoch beim Training zum Beispiel körperlicher Betätigkeit die Temperaturen dort oben ansteigen.
Denn wir haben gemerkt aus den Vorläuferversuchen, teilweise haben wir da ziemlich
hohe Temperaturen gefunden und das könnte unter Umständen nicht so gesund sein,
wie wir das vielleicht Vielleicht hoffen, da müssen wir schauen.
Gibt's doch keine Daten. Also wir sind mit dem Teilbereich dabei und das ist
natürlich auch im Hinblick darauf,
dass man vielleicht später mal Geräte braucht mit denen die Astronauten ihrer,
wenn sie extra regulär arbeiten auf dem Mond oder Mars, dass man das kontrolliert,
die Staubhauttemperatur, weil eben die Wärmeabgabe natürlich in so einem Raumanzug
ist eine sehr komplizierte Geschichte.
Wenn sie zur Sonne hin orientieren, ihren Raumfahrtanzug, da haben sie plus
180 Grad vielleicht, aber im Rücken haben sie minus 100, 120 Grad.
Also sie müssen eine Bekleidung haben, die da über einen Temperaturbereich von einer 250,
300 Grad Unterschied ihren Anzug richtig temperiert, So dass sie da drin nicht
frieren oder nicht das Gefühl haben sie werden da gegrillt drin.
Und dafür wäre es natürlich wichtig, dass wir die Körpertemperatur bei verschiedenen
Aufgaben entsprechend betrachten.
Und da läuft im Augenblick unsere Forschung hin. Aktuell.
Aber wenn man jetzt von einem längeren Aufenthalt auf dem Mond ausgeht,
also es gibt ja so die Ideen Mondbasis zu bauen und dort also wirklich auch
Personal am Start zu haben. Das sind ja dann im Prinzip auch nochmal ganz neue
bisher unbekannte Bedingungen.
Okay also Schwerkraft gibt es immerhin ein bisschen so.
Das fand ich ja überhaupt am lustigsten als wir unseren Parabelflug gemacht haben.
Ich weiß nicht ob das immer gemacht wird aber auf jeden Fall startete erstmal
mit einer nicht ganz optimal oder mit einer anders geflogenen Parabel,
die halt da nicht auf Schwerelosigkeit aus war, sondern die dann erstmal die
Schwerkraft des Mars simuliert.
Das heißt man konnte schon noch so ein bisschen rumhüpfen,
aber man sprang halt schon deutlich höher und die zweite Parabel war dann halt
die Schwerkraft des Mondes, auch funny, konnte man halt so wie so ein kleines
Mondmännchen rumhüpfen.
Es geht natürlich alles so schnell auch wieder weg, weil es sind ja nur 21 Sekunden
und dann ging es eigentlich erst richtig los.
Also würde ich mich jetzt sozusagen auf den Mond aufhalten, dann kennt man ja auch aus den Bildern,
damals von den Mondlandungen kann man halt ordentlich rumhüpfen und das würde
ja dann zumindest schon mal dem Körper helfen erstmal,
das ist ja schon mal ein Vorteil, meinten ja vorhin so ein bisschen,
Schwerkraft wäre immer ganz geil. Ähm...
Aber, was kommt noch mit dazu,
also es ist halt eine Frage der Koordination der gesamten Muskulatur,
wenn sie sagen okay die können ja so sprengen, es gibt ja auch einige Apollo Astronauten,
die haben bei dieser Sprungbewegung auf einmal in so eine Rückenlage hinein
bekommen und haben dann versucht das gegenzusteuern und das klappte dann nicht
so und wenn das natürlich in einer Situation passiert,
wo man vielleicht nicht nur im Regolith landet, sondern halb im Krater oder so.
Kann mir vorstellen das muss noch trainiert werden ja also die abstimmung der
entsprechenden gelenke das entsprechend zu kontrollieren da müssen wir nochmal
ich meine für uns ist ja schon schwierig wenn wir irgendwo hier so ein stöpsel
hinten in den papierkorb werfen
wo wir unsere kraft genau dosieren müssen damit wir die strecke haben,
Und das Ding dann versenken mit der entsprechenden Gewicht was es hat.
Hier müssen wir halt lernen mit dem Raumanzug entsprechende Strecken zu bewegen
und eventuell eben auch dann wiederum in thermisch sehr sehr unterschiedlichen
Bereichen wenn sie durch den Krater hindurch gehen,
da gibt es Bereiche da ist es stockfinster da kommt die Sonne vermutlich nicht hin,
dann verändert sich das gesamte thermische umfeld
und da kommen sie wieder raus und
das müssen sie das muss man ich denke das muss
man alles erstmal lernen sich in dieser umwelt entsprechend ich will nicht sagen
dass das nicht geht das wird schon gehen aber das erfordert dass wir kognitiv
sehr gesund sind diese verschiedenen aufgaben mit kontrolle wie viel habe ich
denn noch sauerstoff wie lange
kann ich hier noch sein wann muss ich meine flüssigkeit zu mir nehmen etc.
Dann sind das natürlich auch balkige Geräte, die selber einen eigenen Widerstand
haben, mit denen muss ich auch trainieren, deswegen das machen die ja teilweise
auch hier schon in Köln-Porz, wenn sie dann in entsprechende große Wassertanks
reingehen und dann überhaupt mal mit diesen Anzügen da arbeiten.
Das ist da in den Simulationsanlagen,
wo man mal so ein bisschen Schwerkraft länger als die 20 Sekunden beim Parabelfloh,
Sondern wo sie bestimmte Sachen mal machen können, wo man merkt,
wie schwierig das dann ist.
Wo man sich mal festhalten muss, ich meine in der Schwerlosigkeit überall wo sie anschauen,
da fliegen sie ganz zack zurück,
also man will was greifen aber wenn sie es nicht greifen dann haben sie sofort
wieder einen Impuls der sie von dem Ding da wegbringt,
also ist es schon, Ok das geht immer alles so ein bisschen von Aktivitäten außerhalb aus,
das ist natürlich nochmal eine Sache, aber angenommen man hätte jetzt so eine Mondbasis,
so ein schickes Häuschen, so eine Kuppel irgendwie die ist dann ordentlich bedruckt,
da ist temperiert, also das sind jetzt erstmal nicht so die Faktoren so,
man hat eigentlich nur die andere Schwerkraft und natürlich muss man gucken.
Sonne ist natürlich jetzt, man hat keinen Tageszyklus.
Doch sehr hoch noch auf dem mond also wenn ich mich recht erinnere wenn man
also dort dann auf dem mond ist dann hat man im prinzip in ein paar monaten
die dosis abbekommen die man hier im ganzen leben auf der erde abbekommen.
Also das muss man schon irgendwie schützen sie werden auch nicht endlos da draußen
rumlaufen können weil sie einfach wiederum das strahlungsproblem die strahlung
ist für die zellen eine große.
Bedrohung und nicht ohne Grund um wieder an den Anfang zurückzukommen,
man kommt immer wieder zur Geologie, zur Evolution zurück.
Warum ist das Leben vermutlich im Wasser entstanden, weil auch da sie natürlich die Möglichkeit haben,
dass sie insbesondere von der UV-Strahlung geschützt sind, denn die DNA ist
sehr empfindlich, wenn es um UV-Strahlung geht, deswegen ist Wasser,
Wasser ist eine super Substanz, um entsprechende Strahlung abzuschirmen.
Insofern spricht auch dafür sehr sehr viel, dass das Leben da im Wasser entstanden ist.
Wenn ich mich recht erinnere, hatten die Großteil der kosmischen Strahlung,
wenn man so eine fünf Meter dicke
Schicht Wasser um ein Raumschiff herum konstruieren würde oder Räume,
in denen die mit fünf meter wasser umspült sind hätte man einen nahezu komplex
wo der sich vor der strahlung schützt also wasser ist ein ausgesprochen vorteilhafte Substanz.
Ist nur schwierig so eine große Wasserseitenblase da hin zu kriegen.
Aber wenn es auf dem Mond, wir hatten ja auch von dem Mond von Stationen geredet,
da könnte man natürlich vorstellen, weil man weiß, okay in verschiedenen Silikaten
oder in bestimmten Punkten ist relativ viel Wasser drin,
es soll auch einzelne Krater geben, insbesondere im Südbereich,
wo man schon mit Satelliten also gefrorenes Wasser nachgewiesen hat.
Tja schauen wir mal würde ich sagen ob es das gibt, wenn es das gibt wird man
sicherlich darauf zurückgreifen und wird das irgendwie nutzen.
Der Strahlenvorteil existiert auch wenn das Wasser gefroren ist nehme ich an.
Das ist eine sehr gute frage wie ob das gleichwertig ist das weiß ich jetzt
nicht kann ich die frage kann ich nicht beantworten.
Weil so unterirdisch wäre es ja also untermondisch wäre es ja sozusagen einfacher
eine gefrorene schicht zu haben.
Als ist flüssiges wasser zu haben ja ja ja.
Es gibt ja so eine eine monde die um den jupiter kreisen die sind ja mehr wasser
vorhanden als bei unseren weltmeeren die sind aber unter einer eisschicht die
so wahrscheinlich so 100 kilometer 120 kilometer dick.
Das wäre hochinteressant zu sehen, wie sich das da, was da sich abspielt unter dem Eis,
aber das lenkt ein bisschen jetzt ab,
also es gibt schon Wasser, Das ist ein bisschen schwerer zu halten,
aber ich denke, da werden auch mal Missionen Ende des Jahrhunderts hingehen
und dann wird man zunächst sehen, wie man robotisch davor sich konnte,
bevor man da Menschen hinschickt.
Medizinische Betrachtung heißt ja auch, ist ja nicht nur die Vorgänge,
sondern auch so ein bisschen die Reparatur, wenn jetzt so jemand längere Zeit auf dem Mond ist,
ich weiß gar nicht was ich meine mit längere Zeit, wie lange würde man für so
eine Mission dort dann realistisch da sein,
schwer zu sagen, ich meine, hängt dann eben auch, Von der Versorgungslage erstmal ab,
30 Tage, 40 Tage, also ein,
zwei Monate in dem Bereich würde man wahrscheinlich erstmal arbeiten,
die ersten werden vielleicht nur kurz,
zwei Wochen und dann muss man sehen, was man auch direkt,
alles ist sehr viel besser, wenn man natürlich direkt dort vor Ort,
viele Sachen produzieren könnte bevor man da irgendwas hinschafft also 3D Drucker
die aus dem Material reguliert alles mögliche erstmal bauen können und fertigen
und dann das Zeug vielleicht auch noch zusammensetzen das wäre natürlich das
eigentlich das günstigste.
Aber wenn es jetzt jemanden auf der ISS wirklich schlecht geht also wirklich,
Das gab es ja glaube ich so bisher noch nicht, gab es schon mal so einen medizinischen
Notfall auf der ISS in dem Sinne?
Ne auf der ISS nicht, es sind auch von der Meerstation aus nicht ganz klaren
Gründen manchmal der eine oder andere zurückgeholt wird,
wo man eher den Verdacht ist, das ist nicht vielleicht das richtige Wort,
aber wo man eher annimmt, das waren psychische Probleme,
die zu einer Unvereinbarkeit der dann da oben sich zusammenfienden Crew entwickelt
hat, wo man gesagt hat, okay komm, die holen wir lieber runter,
als dass die sich da oben nachher irgendwie die Köpfe einschlagen.
Aber richtig medizinische Notfälle hat es noch nicht gegeben.
Es gab ein oder zwei Brände,
an dem einen war der Herr Ewald, der deutsche Astronaut, war an Bord,
als diese Not lag, das sind natürlich kurzfristig sehr sehr kritische Systeme,
das eventuell auch mal irgendein Wrackteil oder sonst was irgendwie mal die
Raumstation da trifft und dann da ein Loch rein schlägt, Das ist ja nur sehr
sehr dünn das Material, also die Gefahr besteht auch immer.
Die war auch schon das eine oder andere teil hat er schon mal ein loch eingegeben.
Also ist auf jeden Fall auf dem Mond nicht so einfach, weil auf der ISS gibt
es zur Not halt die Kapsel, die sind 45 Minuten später, sind die irgendwo in
Kasachstan oder ne Stunde später.
Also auf dem Mond müsste man sich ja sozusagen noch so ein kleines Krankenhaus noch mit dazu denken.
Also die sollten schon so gescreent sein, dass man da nicht unbedingt darum einen Notfall hat,
aber sich selber zu versorgen muss man schon für mehrere Tage können und also,
Ich denke man wird da sehr viel lernen von den stationen die sich zum beispiel
in der antarktis befinden oder sowas was brauchen die was,
was ist an rüstzeug nötig ist es natürlich sehr viel einfacher auf dem mond
entsprechend zum beispiel jemand jetzt zu behandeln,
rein jetzt händisch als in der schwerelosigkeit ich meine einige der versuche
auf der isl haben schon gemacht dann nur mal ein tubus zu schieben oder so etwas
oder auch nur einen zugang zu finden ist alles sehr schwierig in der schwerelosigkeit,
wenn sie dann zugang legen wollen dann muss immer muss der arzt eben auch festgeschnallt
sein und derjenige der dem die entsprechende prozedur,
zugedacht ist der muss auch fixiert sein sonst treiben die immer durcheinander
durcheinander weg ja also das ist nicht ein bisschen schwerkraft macht die sachen
sofort sehr viel einfacher.
Praxismäßig nur schwerelosigkeit ist da schon das eher größere problem schwerkraft macht alles einfacher.
Leichter, das ist ja ein wunderbares, die Schwerkraft macht alles leichter.
Ja das stimmt, man sollte nicht so viel drauf schimpfen, auf die Schwerkraft
kann auch ganz gut sein. Ja.
Herr Gunger, ich glaube jetzt haben wir glaube ich unsere thematische Reise
soweit erstmal abgeschlossen.
Ich will noch kurz die Gelegenheit nutzen auf ein paar relevante Sendungen zu
verweisen, die ich hier schon mal gemacht habe.
Ich habe mich ja unter anderem mit Reinhard Ewald auch über die Feuergeschichte
schon mal unterhalten. Auch schon zwölf Jahre her sehe ich gerade Raumzeit Nummer
10 und wie vorhin schon erwähnt Raumzeit 27 hat sich mit Mars 500 beschäftigt.
Und natürlich habe ich auch noch ein Gespräch über Weltraummedizin mit Herrn Gerzer,
dem Leiter dort beim IAC in Köln, von der Weltraummedizin geführt,
auch schon zwölf Jahre her, ist schon so lange her, Raumzeit 21,
seitdem war erstmal wieder Ruhe im Karton.
Haben wir noch irgendwas wichtiges, ungesagtes, was im Raum, Weltraum steht?
Tja, wir sollten wirklich durch die Raumfahrt den Blickwinkel auf unsere Erde
wirklich sehr verschärfen, was wir ja auch tun.
Dass wir das wirklich global angehen können und die Probleme,
die wir hier nicht lösen können auf der Erde,
einen anderen Lebensraum werden wir so schnell nicht irgendwo finden,
das wird sehr sehr kompliziert.
Also wir sollten uns immer bewusst machen, es ist alles nur geliehen und mit
diesem Geliehen sollten wir verpflichtet nochmal sehr sorgsam umgehen.
Das sind einmalige Verhältnisse hier, wo übersprachen die nächsten Planeten, die man irgendwo,
Sonnensystem betrachten kann sind ziemlich weit weg und nicht so ganz erreichbar
und auf die anderen Planeten sind alle vielleicht noch Titan als Mond vom Saturn aber das ist alles,
auch die anderen Planeten sind entweder zu heiß oder zu weit weg und das ist
alles sehr sehr kompliziert.
Titan auch nur wenn man auf Ammoniak und kalte Temperaturen steht.
Da steht ja, bei minus 200 Grad lebt das eben, wie wir gehört haben auch nicht
so toll, deswegen müssen wir auf diesen Planeten hier achten.
Und was den meisten vielleicht auch gar nicht bewusst ist draußen,
Europa hat mit der ESA, mit der europäischen Raumfahrtbehörde in den letzten
20 Jahren das ausgefuchste System für Umweltbeobachtung der Welt,
wir sind die Weltmeister in den Satelliten.
Das ist eine ganze armada von die über wind
über wasser über temperatur über strahlung über zustand der meere zustand verschiedener
da haben wir satelliten nur an sentinel eins und zwei denke die das im meta
auflösung machen das ist wirklich
das wir sind der weltmeister drin das läuft im stillen im prinzip.
Das ganze Kopernikus Programm.
Das ist wirklich, worauf wir
meiner Ansicht nach in Europa stolz sein und dass wir auf alle Fälle weiter
ausbauen und woran wir weiter arbeiten sollten und insofern leistet da Europa
wirklich eine Hilfestellung.
Jetzt für viele Forschungen, die in der ganzen Welt laufen, wir selber haben
noch Projekte in der Sub-Sahara, wo wir auch diese Satelliten,
benutzen, um zu sehen, wie ist da die thermische Belastung in bestimmten Bereichen
und wie wirkt sich das dann aus auf die Fähigkeit dort zu arbeiten bzw.
Das nötige zum Überleben selber durch Anbau zu erhalten.
Also Raumfahrt ist nicht weit weg,
es kommt immer auf die Perspektive und dann jetzt häufig einfach auch Richtung
Erde gerichtet und das finde ich, sollten wir uns immer bewusst machen.
Ja Erdbeobachtung auf jeden Fall auch wichtiges Thema. War hier auch schon Thema.
Kann ich gleich noch ein paar Sendungen hinterher schieben. Ich hab mich mal
mit Herrn Hans-Joachim Lotz-Iwen unterhalten.
In der Erdbeobachtung ein großer Name.
Und natürlich war auch die Kopernikus-Geschichte hier schon öfter ein Thema.
Unter anderem habe ich mit Josef Aschbacher gesprochen, der damals noch dafür
zuständig war. Jetzt ist er ja der Chef der ESA geworden.
Raumzeit 42, also da ist auch eine Menge zu holen.
So, genug meine eigenen Sendungen geplagt. Jetzt erstmal vielen Dank für die
Ausführungen, Herr Gunga.
Danke sehr für das interessante Gespräch.
Ja und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. Hier bis bald geht es wieder
weiter. Ich sag erstmal Tschüss und bis bald.